what up it's your boy mike rasheed check
me out on the bootleg kev podcast
boulet kev podcast special guest in here
mike rashid welcome what's up sir thanks
for having me of course um
for people who don't know you're
obviously um
i mean mogul i would say i don't know
the definition of a mogul well describe
kind of like what you do man because you
do a lot like there's so many things
that you do i'm a professional boxer
even though i'm not fighting right now
but the right offer comes across i'm on
it
um i love fitness working out i worked
out my entire life
even different like phases of my life
like when i was in the streets i still
worked out you know what i mean
every group of friends that i've had i
was a ring leader getting everybody in
the gym my entire life
um and now you know i'm an entrepreneur
i own businesses
uh i have a sports nutrition business or
supplement supplement business that's
that's kevin gates
was speaking about your ambrosia
pre-workout yeah yeah he's with us
honest that's that's my spiritual
brother right there shout out to kev
yeah um
so yeah so i got ambrosia we got the
number one plant-based protein in the
country it's crazy
uh i have a healthy snack company called
snack house foods
um i own a chunk of
one of the most successful meal prep
delivery companies called trifecta wow
killing it going public soon
uh shout out to greg um yeah and i got
like
things i do on the digital side like um
i have an app for online training and
challenges your youtube channel is great
youtube is popping you know i love
youtube man that's that's that really
was a catalyst for success across all my
businesses yeah youtube yeah i feel like
you are very consistent with the
i feel like you know people do work out
videos and obviously you do interviews
you do just motivational [ __ ] but even
just your workout videos are a lot more
palatable than like
some of the like typical youtube [ __ ]
you'd see that makes sense they're like
more aesthetically like i could watch
this and like you know why because
you're a hip-hop dude right right i'm a
hip-hop dude so you know
people won't realize why they was liking
my videos but it was like i used to rap
right
and the same people that was doing my
beats
and my videos back then were doing my
beats and videos for the fitness stuff
you know what i'm saying is amir perry
doing your stuff yeah shout out to amir
hey real talk when i was growing up in
phoenix i remember he had a situation
with suave house
and uh he was like one of the uh
local guys who like always
it was like him pokeface like there's
like a few guys who had like national
looks
this is prior to the man up well this is
around man up squad this was yeah this
is when
yeah he had his deal already but we we
put together man up squad right around
that time yeah
let's get to so just so you know i met
you when i was like an intern at power
yeah
way back today
now
for people who don't know um i'm
originally from phoenix and there was
you were a really poppin artist in
arizona you went by sin q
and um there was a group which was kind
of crazy like if it really would have
worked out the way it was supposed to
work out man up squad yeah it was like
you willy north pole hot rod mirror it
was yeah i'm missing someone else
was phrasing that phrase was in it but
then we had a thousand like just guys
that was just wanted to be down too yeah
and it was like um
one of the only times where i felt like
in phoenix there was like a real
movement that like
was like oh [ __ ] like imagine if all the
dopest people in your city came together
and like rolled in unison
and um
yeah it was it was dope it was a dope
moment we got we got some magic bro we
got some songs from back then that still
if it was to come out right now with
slap [ __ ] that nobody even heard you
know i mean because we never really put
music out you know like
people knew us uh we hadn't put music
out as a collective right everybody had
to solo projects but you know i take a
lot of responsibility for things coming
apart because you know i was doing
illegal things and
you know you got locked up right yeah i
was on a run for a long time so
basically like with me like i was
selling drugs i was selling weed which
is legal now but you know wholesaling it
to the east coast to new york atlanta uh
a lot of guys in az were doing that oh
yeah a lot of guys are the hip hop side
right oh no no for sure you already know
you already know
so so i know some of them through that
right but
my life i'm so authentic
i was being authentic all the way across
the board you know what i'm saying so
i'm making money here but i'm doing
other things in the streets that i
probably shouldn't have been doing what
i'm saying and it all caught caught up
to me so
you know a lot of violence a lot of in
arizona it's a huge state but it's small
everybody knows each other and the cops
know everything yeah you know i mean so
they're bored man they're bored you know
they know everything to a t because not
only do they know everything but
literally everybody out there is
snitching like 100
100
they was going so hard on me i had to
hire
an investigator to find out what was
really going on because i thought maybe
there was some other secret indictment
you know what i'm saying because there
was some other [ __ ] might have been
coming in yeah i was nervous damn
something like they got they got a heart
on from me for some reason
and i had when they got me i know priors
so uh come to find out there was people
that i was around pretty big people you
know what i'm saying
that had major cases that
were throwing me under the bus you know
even it was like hearsay stuff because i
kept everybody out of my business you
know i'm saying my operation was small
oh
is that my phone or your phone that's
that's yours jesus siri mine don't talk
english so
hey take my phone though siri picking up
what we're doing
that's weird anyway continue yeah but so
anyway we found out that
you know i like everything like
people they would always ask about me
and people would give their opinion on
what i was doing
and one of the guys that goes to his
name um i looked out for we caught cases
around the same time but his with state
and federal he was he was done for but
he
he he worked with them but he came over
recording me with a uh in the key fob a
microphone or key fob was this a
person in this on the scene in phoenix
at the time good no comment he owes him
but yeah was it a dj nah okay okay but
anyway um so he they got me they heard
me saying really bad things you know
what i'm saying because i'll be trying
to figure things out i'm like somebody
snitching and you know you know what
comes with that
so it was stuff that was not admissible
in court but it seasoned the perspective
or the perception of my my prosecutor
you know what i'm saying and they try to
use man up squad as a gang and they say
i was a gang leader kind of like this
this [ __ ] they're doing with the ysl
yeah you know what i'm saying so they
but
i was like [ __ ] that so i had to have a
whole
like trial
to prove they have to prove that i am a
gang leader and manos squad was a gang
and they they didn't have nothing on it
because they gotta they gotta um show
that there were two or three felonies
committed in the name of the
organization to certify it as a gang and
pete this [ __ ] this is [ __ ] up
if
now first of all when they put you uh
put a gang junction on you
most people don't don't try to fight it
right right right and most people say
yeah i'm in such and such gang they just
[ __ ] themselves right so anyway that's
an additional 10 years on top of
anything that that happens if you're if
you're considered in a gang if you have
a two year burglary you're getting 12
years
just because you're in a quote-unquote
gang right
wow targeted [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying and it's crazy because like you
know when you if you think about like a
guy like a hot rod he was like a
mortgage guy before he was right yeah a
lot of the guys were
not involved in anything some of them
amir that's like my brother right there
man but great producer man great person
all around he separated himself and i'm
glad that he did because
the people that i was really like were
really friends of mine they just seen
the direction and they was like i ain't
with that [ __ ] and i'm glad they did
and um so
you know at the end of the day it was
just me standing there you understand
but i handled it like a man i i did run
for a minute how long were you on the
run
seven years seven years so give me the
year to year like
2007 six years 2007 everything happened
i caught two cases 107 108
and 07
it got kind of like dismissed but
without uh without prejudice so they
could bring it back right
it was really a weak case you know um
and
so i'm out you know um and 08 i caught
another case
and i'm trying to like at this point i'm
trying to really like straighten up you
know what i'm saying
um actually in 07 i was trying to
straighten up but it was like
people always say when you're making
that kind of money fast money like i'm
gonna i'm gonna get x amount and then
get out it's impossible you know what
i'm saying i mean yeah it's it's i'm
sure it can happen but it's really hard
you know i mean because it comes so fast
you spin it just as fast as you get it
because you know you can get it again
yeah i mean so
i was like [ __ ] i just got to keep
getting it and me fighting cases was
expensive
so i'm fighting cases ankle bracelet
still trapping you know what i'm saying
so
so 08
um caught another case they came and got
me um i had a bunch of guns at my house
and
they brought the other case they brought
both cases back simultaneously so they
can get me
on felony release with weapons
so they tried some slick [ __ ] pulled me
over in the middle of the street
it was so over the top i'm like all
right
shotguns and [ __ ]
um but
you know you go through the horseshoe
and you see the judge in 24 hours
and
she was like okay well
she's about to say the bond and this
[ __ ] woman on the side like actually
your honor he doesn't get a bond he's a
dangerous violent felon
these are serious crimes and he has all
of these like aks you know arizona that
[ __ ] legal
right you know what i'm saying but it
just looked bad yeah i don't even think
it was as legal back then though as it
is now because now it's like it was it
was super it was legal but i think now
like
okay i know what it is it's a it's a law
that they got that saved my life called
uh stand your ground
no castle doctrine that's what it's
called they didn't have it when my [ __ ]
happened right because everything that
happened happened in my house i'm saying
uh you know so
but i was gone for so long by the time
they got me they had that law so if
you're on the run so you find out you're
essentially looking at serious time yeah
and you decide to just say [ __ ] it i
said i'll tell you listen i live life
life don't live me nothing happens to me
i do i you know and i'm not like saying
that in an egotistical way but i will
not allow somebody else to determine my
fate it's not happening
and i didn't feel like what they were
trying to get if they would have said
like three years five years i was like
all right it's about 15 to 20 years with
no priors that's crazy like this ain't
happening so you mean tell me my kids
are gonna be adults when i get out nah
cool and you know and people don't
realize
uh with a violent offense
especially something of the nature of
mine you're in a way worse type of
facility is gladiator school you know
what i'm saying so i'm like i know i'm
gonna be in there having to defend
myself catching more cases so it just
looked bleak you know what i'm saying so
i'm like no i'm good i'm out of here so
where'd you go
all over you know all over the country
drew and
i left the country for four minutes um
and then like
me you know i stayed in communication
with my children and
i was like what the [ __ ] am i doing like
i i went on a run
so they won't separate me from my kids
but you're separating yourself i'm
separated from my kids so i came back
and um
you know i came back everybody figured
that i would have got caught by that you
know i'm saying
but i just don't move reckless i
calculate everything i study everything
about look i'm i was a valedictorian
student all my life you know what i'm
saying honor student all of that [ __ ] so
i just did research
and seeing what i can do
what in cics whatever that shit's called
what do they track everything i looked
up everything so i moved around so um
when i got back people did think that i
was gonna get got caught by then and
then some of my friends they were like
yo you could stay with me you could come
back i'm like cool but when i came back
it was a surprise to them
so they was like i don't know and
rightfully so because this [ __ ] probably
wasn't 100 you know what i'm saying and
i'm bringing heat to them
so i didn't even it didn't bother me i'm
glad that no one allowed me to come stay
because it just put a certain type of
motivation
a little certain fire under me so i was
legit homeless for a minute bro and pete
this
i'm homeless right
i had like
i still had [ __ ] in the streets like
whips and [ __ ] like that other people
subleasing it and like [ __ ] was
talking [ __ ]
people that was nothing to me you know
what i'm saying i'm like what
so i was at a crossroad
i was you know full of fear full of
anger
full of confusion you know what i'm
saying when you got nothing
i have nothing right i don't it looks
like i don't have a future
only i had was like violence and and
physical force and intimidation so i'm
gonna just
go to my
my my default settings and i'm knocking
on doors so i really was about to like
go back to arizona
you know what i'm saying and just ruin
my life
but
so when you you came back into the
country you you were in cali yeah okay
but i didn't because if you would have
went to arizona you would have just
started i would have been making your
rounds
for what i think nothing comes out of
that yeah
so what stopped me was my son you know
what i'm saying
his mother who's very smart
she made a
weird call and was like hey you want
your son
here i am she don't even realize i'm
homeless
nobody knew that [ __ ] right i'm like
yeah i didn't know how i was gonna take
him or whatever but i figured that [ __ ]
out so that saved my life you know what
i mean and it was one day um i started
getting my [ __ ] together i'm taking him
to school then i have a call i'm walking
and
he little like six right
kindergarten maybe something like that
and or first grade so welcome to school
um
when i when he comes out i'm there and
you know he can't see me because he's
little i could see him i see him looking
for me and i seen this one day bro his
eyes lit up when he seen me and just ran
just hugged onto my leg and then held my
hand tight and we walked home and i was
thinking like [ __ ]
like
this little perfect little human loves
me
i ain't got no car
i got no fly [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
and you know when i had all of that [ __ ]
i had nothing but fake love around me
you know what i mean
but this guy loves me you know i'm
saying unconditionally unconditionally
so it made me love myself you know what
i mean
and
[ __ ] has been good ever since then bro
you know man so did you ever resolve
being on the run with the law
enforcement don't tell nobody
nah yeah i did i did they actually
they came they found me in 2014 the us
marshals they came and got me outside
the gym
and uh
the marshall
it was weird that i was on social media
period but
i was on social media initially to stay
in touch with my family you know i'm
saying
um
so
i would i started working as a personal
trainer and i would use social media for
my clients like showing their progress
right videos promote your business yeah
right and it would give me a lot more
business every now and then i throw a
little video of myself working out and
people were just liking all the content
and then it got to where there's more
demand for it and i'm like [ __ ] it like
every day you want to run
you're you're not thinking you're free
but
you feel a little more comfortable every
day
while there's this invisible weight
hanging in the back of your head it's a
dark loud yeah dark loud
bad way to live i'm sure it was not not
really it was
it was stressful but stress is good
depending on how you deal with it right
okay stress will make you powerful or to
break you you know what i'm saying it
just made me strong so
and it gave me a certain sense of
urgency to live and to be in the moment
in the moment because yeah you never
know because every day every day bro
there's many days that i'm imagining
them
in my life at the door of my apartment
worst case scenario 15 to 20 is serious
so everybody like every day and then as
a as a fugitive it's an enhancement foj
enhancement so
you know you're looking at more time you
know i'm saying
so
so uh what happened where were we at we
were we were talking about how you were
working out the us marshals campaign
so social media so my [ __ ] just started
going viral i'm like [ __ ] i can't even
stop it
well [ __ ] it we'll see what happens and
then it's like people who's like
reaching out to come train with me and
[ __ ] like that and i'm like tell them
1500 it's like okay i'm like damn i'm
making money and a lot of cops was
coming to work out with me you know what
i'm saying so i'm like what the [ __ ] you
know but the cops military those are
like a huge part of my like my base like
i just love that kind of like discipline
and that hard work and [ __ ] like that
so and they just guys too you know what
i'm saying so
yeah i developed
i i built i rebuilt my life right from
nothing
the right way all legal all ethical
everything
crossed my t's down my eyes doing the
most right and then they came and got me
and
i ain't gonna lie kev i was like i was a
little bit relieved you know
because
i had to lie to everybody all the time
nobody knew [ __ ]
nobody knew nothing right and i wasn't
directly telling people oh i did i i'm
from here or i did this
but i would walk people down a a
neighborhood of you know what i want
them to believe from my past you know
what i'm saying
so
uh i didn't want to do that [ __ ] so i
was like [ __ ] i got a lot in one and the
the martial that got me he was like yeah
man
we've been trying to get you for a
minute but you always you travel a lot
so he's always a couple days behind you
and i'm like [ __ ] that's crazy but he
was like yo you're a good dude and you
do a lot of good for a lot of people he
said just get this behind you and move
on with your life
and i was like thank you but in my head
i'm like
my life about to be with y'all you know
what i'm saying
but make a long story short uh you know
they move me around all over cali
um everywhere i'm at cops just pulling
me out like what are you doing here you
know what i'm saying like guards and
[ __ ] because they're always into working
out and [ __ ]
and i'll ask some old [ __ ] whatever so
they kept me here as long as they could
because i couldn't bond out here because
arizona
finally to extradite me
and um
was a half million dollars i was like
yeah
so but i did make bond
and then i got a bomb ass attorney fired
he just beat the [ __ ] out of the case
bro wow he did so
he was whooping them like he was so
aggressive you know i'm saying like i'm
telling him like yo you should probably
chill like you're gonna piss them off
he's like [ __ ] them i'm gonna make them
work
and uh he did he tried to he made them
work and um he was so confident he just
made me listen if i would have went to
prison at the end of it right you would
have been like at least we tried i would
have been the route to it i wouldn't
have been stressed out because he was so
competent and confident you know what
i'm saying you didn't like it probably
the worst thing that could ever happen
is
you hire a lawyer with your freedom in
the
in the in the limb and and it's a shitty
lawyer oh yeah and the first one i hired
was yeah he was scared of everything he
was a [ __ ] like for
he was such a coward you know what i'm
saying
because initially he was like we're
going to ask for a bond reduction
because that's not constitutional yada
yada so when they finally got to where
they assigned a prosecutor they still
didn't assign a prosecutor
but they gave that somebody had to show
up to court
and you know
he didn't want to do the bond reduction
and they coming to me panicking they
scaring me because they scared i'm like
what what what happened like there's
something i don't know about
so when i i just
ran the model through my head i'm like
these [ __ ] guys are scared
there's nothing i don't even have a
prosecutor yet they don't give you a
prosecutor that fast especially for a
big case right
um i'm buying it out of this [ __ ]
because he was like save your money i
was like i sat there an extra month
trying to save money
but [ __ ] that i got out so yeah
he worked for about a month then i seen
how uncompetent he was and i got rid of
him and got uh shout out to brian russo
smite guy brian russo russo naisi he's a
g he's he's my he's one of my best
friends like that i love that man for
life yeah [ __ ] he beat the case man beat
it so you only had to sit down for about
a month
a couple months okay yeah and um but
that's i mean you know that's manageable
not bad bro and listen when people
anybody's been locked up it's like
the worst day is the first day you in
there well especially in arizona that
horseshoe you gotta you're sitting in
there with all these it's the worst the
worst [ __ ] is they changed it by the way
arizona i don't even want to know i may
or may not have been there recently yes
it's a lot better maricopa county l.a
county and dade county are the three
worst jails in the country you know what
i'm saying
so you've lived in all three places none
two well i've been in two of them okay
oh you've been like
yeah so
not humane conditions well they changed
it uh with the new sheriff but then
covid happened and now when you go to
when you go to jail for like
you know usually they'd send you to like
madison and you're sitting in a room
with
they send you to like a wait you take a
number and you're in a waiting room
you're not even in cuffs it's kind of
crazy it's weird it's funny it seemed
like that would be cool but you want to
be around people
yeah
being isolated is not the vibe not that
first like when you're like super like
if you get arrested on for some dumb
[ __ ]
that first like night or day when you're
like you didn't expect it happening you
don't want to
bro i've been in jail [ __ ]
recognized me
and they asked like what are you doing
here i mean i was only in for like a day
or two but like it's like [ __ ] man like
yeah that just sucks bro the first day
is the worst you know what i'm saying
but then once
you just get normal you're used to once
you get a bed i'm sure yeah right yeah
that's the best like just just give me a
bit so bad they make it so bad that you
get something like a bed you're like oh
i'm good and it's a shitty bed oh yeah
yeah yeah it's like yeah you don't have
to use that a roll of toilet paper as a
pillow anymore
but um but they but out here they had me
at the uh
the old county jail i heard la county
jail's a wild place it is but we was in
the max security so it's single man
sales
and it's bars like you don't see bars
that's like on tv yeah like they rolled
his wheel for the bars uh you know i'm
saying
and bro
you ever read the book of revelations
or the rapture
i'm i'm familiar with it i'm i'm i'm not
a religious man so i'm not neither am i
but i'm fascinated by literature and
that's a fascinating piece of literature
revelations that give the the
description of hell right
bro i'm telling you l.a county jail the
mass security side was literally
identical because they said
gabriel throws you into like the pit of
hell right like violently throws you and
then in the walls just
down the tunnel is like so stuck right
screaming and reaching for you and you
never hear silence you know what i'm
saying and in there it's it's like you
you're going down down these halls
[ __ ] you know hanging out
bro nobody they'd never stop talking
all night and i'm talking about the most
ignorant [ __ ] you'll ever hear you know
what i'm saying [ __ ] on the top
tier talking to the bottom tier they
never met each other you know what i'm
saying just talking about their baby
mamas like the dumbest [ __ ] so it's like
for a person who
i mean i'll never say that i didn't
deserve to be there you know because
everything happens for a reason but that
wasn't my life anymore
it's it's that part alone was torture
just listening to everybody just because
you're like i don't belong here bro i
listen i listen to
audio books and you know saying
i make some classical music in with my
hip hop and i like hearing i'm a fan of
like different intellectuals in in the
academia space
and i got to hear this
you're like why am i like this is this
isn't this this can't be
not life but i still get a try like it's
my punishment i just [ __ ] deal with
it i'm saying
because i did do i did do i did things
that wasn't cool and it was people i
looked up to me and that that followed
me
down dark paths you know what i'm saying
and that [ __ ] is never cool you know
yeah i mean back then like with that
0.506 era of pushing packs was it was
also very um
a lot more
money was
the margins were greater oh man because
the margins nowadays like i don't even
know they're just not i mean obviously
with the availability of weed right the
secrets out you can come to l.a there's
instagram pages with distro like it's
kind of wild like the i don't know what
those guys are doing now i know they
sick today's stomach so take me back to
like 0.506 what would be like
average that you would pay for a pack
and would you get it off on the east
coast the average is 500 for a pound you
know that reggie that that error that
ahri they call it arizona they got the
purple hairs the popcorn
the good texture but it's just regular
weed outdoor [ __ ] outdoor boy on the
east coast that's like some fire [ __ ] so
the smaller the town the more you get
there was some place in georgia we were
getting [ __ ] off like twelve thirteen
hundred dollars a pound yeah but like
atlanta you getting like to nine eight
hundred dollars new york seven
but i had a um
i had a [ __ ] hell of a plug though so
my connect in a z was a pisa right
always is so no no it's usually uh
chicano right well yeah pisces for
people who don't know what a pie says
the price is like straight from mexico
chicano's a person who's born here
that's america right
uh an american with mexican descent
paisa is a mexican from mexico yeah you
bring the work cheap to the chicano the
chicanos usually to connect right but my
connect was a paisa that just is kind of
like a chicano because he grew up in
america but he's from mexico
so he was still giving me average prices
maybe like 50 less or whatever and he
was my homie so one night we went out i
never hung out with him but
he had the typical stereotypical mexican
tolerance of alcohol and he got [ __ ]
up right
and [ __ ] with people and then we
turned around he getting jumped
so i went and saved the day you know
what i'm saying and um after that he was
like bro
you saved my life yada yada i'm gonna
start hooking you up so he started
giving me the work at his cost you know
what his cost was bro what 150 dollars
you're just printing money bro so i was
just like at that point i'm sending [ __ ]
off and i'm telling the biggest thing
was like getting your money back in a
timely fashion and then over time it's
getting more competitive more people was
getting work right so it's taking longer
for my guys to break down the packs and
give me my bread so i was able to like
yo send me 600 650 that way they had it
cheaper they sent my [ __ ] right away
yeah or just buy it yeah man yeah and i
was able to just middle man like come
get it for 400. yeah just come come
somebody if you come to arizona you
handle getting them to where you need to
get it you get it yourself yeah yeah
because then that's the worst thing is
like
when people like want you to put put the
like the works just in the air yeah and
your money's not there yet but the
biggest like stress was like when a pack
go out
i'm waiting to hear that touchdown in
the morning you know what i'm saying so
and i always well man i did it so long
bro with clean streaks never a box
missing
uh i had we had a driver it's amazing
he would give us an address
take it off his route boom it was smooth
you know what i'm saying yo you were
mentioning that you did some research
earlier uh on how to stay out of the way
if you're on the run well by the way
what country did you end up in i don't
really okay tell those things um but
what were some of the things like if
somebody who's watching this and they're
like i'm about to
what are the things that you learned
that they they look out for that
you kind of i don't know what it is
right now but back then back then i
would this is something that i was
afraid of
that i think they do now like
i went you know when you get out of jail
they scan your eyes to make sure the
wrong person not getting released
that technology was brand new back then
and i remember getting to one country
and they were doing a retina scan and i
was shook stressed but nothing happened
because nothing was connected yeah the
database is working yeah these countries
are not connected matter of fact the
states are not connected each state has
like two or three states that they're
connected to they do they they
whichever they feel would be the most
likely that people will go to so
new york i mean california georgia is
not connected you know i've had like uh
outstanding like i think i had a warrant
in arizona once but i was living in
idaho at the time and i was
some traffic [ __ ] none serious but i was
like super freaked out
they pulled me over and they're like
you're good to go sir and i was like hmm
you sure about that you want to run that
again all right
i'll take it
but yeah but yeah so
i mean if you
if you've been in now
these countries aren't connected unless
it's some high profile case
or
if it's a murder
if it's some kind of rape sexual assault
or anything to do with children
you're in the highest uh search [ __ ]
and that's ncic or something like that i
might be saying it wrong but they're
tracking
passports id all that [ __ ] all over the
place unless you got somebody else's
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
so
that's one thing um a lot of crimes go
under the radar they got to know you
there and then you could do your
research there's a google search to see
which countries have uh
uh extradition treaty with united states
because not all of them do
i'm saying so
you could beat someone like yo i'm here
[ __ ] and if there's no treaty in
place they won't you're fine you're good
you may
and i was gonna say you may have a hard
time with visas but you don't because
americans
pretty much every country we go to
except for australia and canada we have
an automatic visa now it'll run out and
all you do is go to the next country
to renew your visa get a just do get
stamped boom come right back 30 bucks
you know what i'm saying crazy i had to
do that [ __ ] a lot
we always like see in the movies uh
nowadays probably like like would you
swap out sim cards and [ __ ] or like have
your oh then yeah i just whatever
wherever i was i got a phone for there
just a little trap phone yeah it's
this it's crazy man you you realize like
being in other countries i realize how
fortunate we are here
i'm talking about other like
first world countries it's like just
having
an abundance of legit cell phone
companies you know what i'm saying yeah
some places only have like one or two
yeah
yeah and it's shitty it's kind of like
prepaid vibes you know what i'm saying
um but now so that that's easy
um you i feel like
well here's the thing typically when
people are on a run they're doing
illegal things to keep themselves afloat
and that's how they get caught you know
i mean i didn't
so i had a little bit of bread
saved right that i was living off of uh
while i was moving around and i had um
one of my partners who
he caught a case you know behind me
i bonded them out did everything load
them up then they dropped the case on
them so i got that money back from the
lawyer you know what i'm saying
so i had a little bit to keep me afloat
for a little bit you know what i'm
saying but by the time i came back to
the states i was running running low you
know what i mean i had to get a job like
a nine to five
what was your what was your first job
coming back i was a just a personal
trainer at a gym
and that obviously proved to be uh
lokia did pretty pretty well pretty well
yeah uh where are you originally from
like from brooklyn new york so you're
originally from brooklyn um
what like
the boxing thing because you know what's
your youtube channel i've been a
subscriber for a while but i was just
like yeah i'm just curious what's the
most popular [ __ ] the most popular
videos uh you give them boxing lessons
yeah um so how like
walk me through kind of growing up in
brooklyn and what resulted in you
getting into fighting and all that yeah
um brooklyn is super competitive it's is
like an overpopulated place
so you're always competing playing
sports fighting everything so i just
kind of grew up with that aggressive
competitive nature and then my my
grandfather my pops introduced me to
boxing at early age
i just thought it was the best sport it
was beautiful because
i grew up when mike tyson was ranting
right so i'm watching mike tyson and his
[ __ ] is poetic you know i'm saying it
wasn't like a boring era you know what i
mean that was a great it was probably
the best heavyweight era ever yeah he's
just in terms of energy smaller than
everybody and crushing giants you know
what i'm saying so i just i loved it so
my father sent me a pair of boxing
gloves and i just took him outside and
just scrapped with everybody and then um
when i got about 12 i got into it um you
know as a sport like as amateur boxing
that's when i had my first fight and i
just
bro i fell in love with it it was over
from there over from there i still i
love it like a [ __ ] now like
it was a period when i had quit
and i couldn't watch boxing because it
was guys that i knew
guys that like you you knew they weren't
sparred with whatever but they stuck to
the script and they're making millions
of dollars so it just pained me you know
i'm saying but that's my own fault you
know what i mean so you think if you
would have stuck with boxing 100 you'd
be one of those guys for sure
everybody was like yeah he's that guy
because
here's the thing i didn't have any
support though you know what i'm saying
it was just me
in new york
anywhere i just mean i just traveled all
over so i didn't have any support with
boxing nobody my
my father was with it but
it's an expensive you got to have a
trainer right you got to go to a gym
yeah that's free though like it's free
that's really like i mean in the poor
areas they do that [ __ ] for free so you
you pay for your book your medicals your
parents pay for that [ __ ] it's not it's
not expensive like that and then the
gyms that i grew up in there's
there's a bunch of we share the gloves
you know what i'm saying so
and and that's really the best case
scenario like when you give people these
kids like all this nice [ __ ] they soft
you know what i'm saying
so my gym
we just pick gloves they stunk they
smell like blood and sweat and just
everybody who's worn them yeah
everybody's knuckles unscraped off in
the gloves like you know what i'm saying
but we didn't see nothing wrong with it
our our our the the tarp in our rain was
just full of blood drops just brown
stains everywhere but that was normal to
us
um i go back i go to some gyms now with
kids training i'm like this how can you
be motivated in here with air
conditioning you know what i'm saying
for real bro you don't you sweat you
can't sweat in them spots so it's too
plush you know what i'm saying like my
son knows all about he got hands but i
would never let him compete because it's
a certain thing that you you don't get
having a a
a privileged life you know what i'm
saying and you don't need to like his
best asset is his brain his mind so i
don't want him damaging that and you
will damage your brain 100 you will
damage it what was it um was it the rap
[ __ ] that got you out of boxing like for
you to start pursuing your rap cricket
because you took your rap [ __ ] seriously
it was
that was part of it but it was like
hustling like making money because look
boxing you boxing to make money
like let's not it takes a while before
you start making sure it takes a while
and i was in mike tyson's camp you know
what i'm saying it was like some light
at the tunnel in the tunnel but the [ __ ]
was hard bro you know i'm saying because
it's a very disciplined lifestyle
you don't do all the [ __ ] your friends
do i'm so glad that i had it though
because even though i went off course
and and was in the streets for a while i
never went but so far and i had
discipline you know what i'm saying
because there's people like you know
some names i ain't gonna say on here i'm
sure you know people out there who did
the most and they're it's a wrap now you
know what i'm saying oh yeah so
i never
the like at the sentencing for my [ __ ]
the judge said
we see that you're not a criminal get
out of my courtroom you know what i'm
saying so it's like the core of me is
not a street criminal whatever you know
what i'm saying i think you're an
entrepreneur i'm an entrepreneur and at
the time i mean that was uh look at the
end of the day man hustlers are hustlers
bro that's it
sometimes the opportunity presents
itself for you to be a hustler in a
legal way right and in the illegal way
it's interesting man i had a
conversation with this dude um
and in the fitness industry it's a lot
of suckers man like virtual signaling
and [ __ ] listen buddy i swear it is
rough some of these guys on youtube or
just instagram like they're cornballs
for sure and we were talking about some
shoes a big discussion
and the guy was trying to like without
saying me like [ __ ] on me by saying like
well you know i've never never been
arrested never did a crime never been in
a fight for all that matter
and i was like that's because you're a
[ __ ] you know i'm saying
you've never did a crime because you're
afraid that you'll get caught and you're
afraid of consequences you know what i'm
saying
because i think listen i'm not saying
committing a crime is ethical is not
right
breaking the law is not okay right but
some laws what if you have your own
consciences like why is this illegal you
know what i'm saying and then i'm going
to take a risk right
i'll weigh out the the risk versus the
reward and if i'm going to live with the
confidence
i'm gonna go right that [ __ ] plays well
into my life now you know what i'm
saying i take all the risks
because ain't nothing bad gonna happen
but i lose some money you know i'm
saying before it was like lose money go
to jail somebody [ __ ] your girl they
just take your card like you know what
i'm saying so that's not even a
a possibility anymore so i'm the
ultimate risk taker you know what i'm
saying and i'm not a and it just
diminished my fear of a lot of things
you know
fear let me say this fear is a sign of
intelligence let's not get it twisted
but
you know fear will also keep you from
living you know i'm saying and
experience in life at its highest so
this is this
to this day it's a it's a risk that i
still take you know what i'm saying yeah
i think like uh
when you're conditioned in society to
live life a certain way
and that way usually is
getting a good job getting your benefits
um just making sure your bare
necessities are covered go on vacation
once a year if you can afford it right
get a nice like decent nice get your
charger with your payment whatever it is
right like
the thought of like
if you if you are making 45 000 a year
60 000 a year but maybe you have some
sort of passion or some sort of
i don't know want for more but you're
scared that like you're gonna walk away
from the sure thing and that sure thing
is [ __ ] bro i'm telling you about it
you're right bro
like the short thing is we got a lot of
people [ __ ] up bro i look at life like
this man like
for me
the most valuable currency is this is
human
it is deep meaningful connections with
people that i think are dope right
um
i live my life predicated on the fact
that i'm gonna die let's not get it
twisted i'm gonna die we're all gonna
die one day right so
for me bro it's like i want people to
have a dope last
memory of me you know what i'm saying
like yo he was a nice guy or
that [ __ ] was dope whatever
whatever it is i want people to have a
pleasant memory of me because look
that's all we have really is the you
know they're going to miss you
they have some memories and that should
start fading then there's just nothing
i'm saying so
i leave a couple things i want to leave
as many positive memories as possible
but then for my children i leave like my
mind in them you know i'm saying i
instill
the the tenants and principles that i
live by in them but i do it better than
what i what i did you know what i'm
saying i give them a better
uh uh
a map for navigating life so that they
can do the same and that's how we keep
the bloodline going it's not even real
blood it's like just a mentality a
consciousness that's passed down through
the generations and you know i've done
my genealogy and you know i got
you know they they track people's
genomes by documents right that's all we
have to go off of so i've been back far
but that's it so i don't know nothing
about
their personalities what they was into
what people thought right right right
now we got this
we are mortal you know what i'm saying
well i was gonna say with like you
anybody who's like seriously into the
content game like you could pass away
but your content is going to live on
forever that's a beautiful thing it's
digital
so i'm very cognizant of that so um
that's what i love doing content listen
a lot of my content the [ __ ] that i love
doing the most don't get the biggest
push right but that's okay because it's
like a series called mental jewels
and it'd be like just me giving certain
perspectives on life on whatever advice
right and it'd be people that hit me up
there like damn bro i used to always
skip these videos but
i was going through some [ __ ] and this
one came on today it actually just hit
me a certain way i just want to say
thank you i do it for that [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying because yeah i mean like
at the end of the day like
it's those small like
we know it gets views and sometimes
you'll do something that you didn't
expect to go viral but for the most part
like you kind of can do something and
know okay this is gonna do what it's
gonna do
but it's like this the [ __ ] that like
isn't the sexiest yeah that really
penetrates people the most pause and um
[Music]
that's like stuff people can live with
that's not going to be the big headline
it's not going to be the
you know the positive
like
i think like even in the interview game
like i'll do interviews that have like 5
000 views
but like i'll i'll get the most feedback
yeah it's see it's depth versus the
width right so and even how you two work
i've been doing youtube since 2012 right
and i've had my reps and i picked their
brand i'm trying to figure out how to
[ __ ] work how we get paid for real
and from what they don't have they don't
ever say exactly how because they want
to prevent fraud of course actually so
but i got an idea and it's not the
amount of views it's the length of time
people are watching your [ __ ]
i'll drop a two hour interview
and i'll clip i i'll drop it i'll drop
that interview and then i'll drop clips
right but the
big interview is where people will sit
for 30 minutes right you make the most
off of that right bro so think about
think about that bro you have a
30-minute two-hour tv show but people
watching like 30 minutes of that [ __ ]
that's a lot of times it's not scripted
it's real it's raw that's value you know
i mean so
um and then even like if i market a
product or something and i have this
beautifully edited video people don't
give a [ __ ] but if i'm just saying some
[ __ ] on my account it's organic that's
what they care about that's why i always
say that when people do ads or they do
anything like in like influencer related
i'm like yo don't over produce it man
just [ __ ] it's gotta it's gotta feel
organic or people are gonna be like [ __ ]
this it's gotta be holistic yeah you
know what i'm saying and what i mean by
by that is like
for me everything is like i try to like
come from a spiritual place
so
like a lot of guys come to me for advice
with business and it's not a third and
i'm like what are you trying to do
they're always concerned about the
outcome and that's money how much they
can make well how much you make from
this i'm like bro i gotta be honest with
you
um i've never went into any of these
businesses with the idea of how much
money i'm gonna make
i went into it with the idea of like yo
i'm going to make the best xyz
and people are going to be happy you
know what i'm saying and i'm going to be
able to price it affordable or whatever
or my service i'm going to be the best
at whatever i'm trying to do for people
and let the le the rest figure itself
out
everything works out you're controlling
what you can control right
and that's all you should worry about
and as a result of that the bad comes
yeah always it's not even
i don't worry about [ __ ] it always comes
you know i'm
that's some real [ __ ] i think like uh
that's one thing people get caught up in
and also intent of what you're doing
like if you're doing something to get
money quick
and you're trying to like have longevity
usually that's not really how it works
you got to have some sort of passion or
some sort of like uh
care for what the passion like you're
into you're into fitness this is what
you do this is not like you're not like
some
some like rich dude who decided oh
there's good money in supplements right
let me start my own supplement line
right right is
i'm an influencer let me start my own
protein
just because
hey big bro how do i start a line i'm
like why what [ __ ] like what if you got
to ask me that [ __ ] you ain't cut out
for this [ __ ] like there's people
there's producers and there's consumers
in this world you know what i'm saying
producers
figure out like you want something like
when i started the supplement game
i never took supplements all my life
until i started getting like worn down
training so many people i ain't got no
energy
try like a fat burner pre-workout
whatever that she gave me energy but it
gave me like weird side effects bro just
itchy arms all that [ __ ] alanine so i go
and i started taking pictures of every
supplement label
after work long as uh days i'm falling
asleep every night with my computer on
my my laptop on my chest researching
looking up these ingredients trying to
identify
what is it that gives me the energy
what is it that gives me these side
effects i didn't like
can this work without that you know what
i'm saying then i start ordering [ __ ]
from china cheap [ __ ] testing on myself
that's how i started this [ __ ] right so
you would make your own stuff i'm a
producer right like you're a producer
you know what i'm saying so
but most of the world are consumers it's
a small amount of people providing goods
and services
and most people need they need somebody
to provide it so they can buy it and
that's fine that's how the world is i
was explaining that to my son
because he was like
he was talking about like kids at school
like they're kind of simple i like look
son don't look at it like that this is
the normal order of things the natural
order of things
most people are that are that and that's
fine there's no knock to them that's
just how it is
it's very people got to understand this
the essence of life of all biological
life on this planet
is to be lazy is efficiency to not do
much you know i'm saying i'ma sit still
till i'm hungry
i'm hungry and i'm gonna get some food
you know what i'm saying a lion we look
at them as so badass right the
[ __ ] just chill like they women
go hunt
oh you got it all right move get out get
out the [ __ ] way i'm eating first you
know what i'm saying that's the nature
the natural order of things people are
not designed to be hustling
people design a chill to relax to rest
you know what i mean so
there's a few weirdos that like to do a
lot of [ __ ] you know what i'm saying and
we as we're in the animal kingdom but
we're a little bit different because we
got these [ __ ] robust cerebral cortex
which the other animals don't so we have
imagination
empathy we can remember things we got
language so we got all these different
ways of like recording information and
passing it down and we learn more pass
it down learn more so we know that we
can and
we know we can do certain things that
are that may seem difficult to do but it
gives us pleasure you know i'm saying
you ever climb like [ __ ] peak or camo
back back in the day yeah yeah that [ __ ]
hard super but when you get to the top
you feel good yeah it's it's especially
in arizona depending on how hot it is
yeah
it's a certain sense of accomplishment
most people will never even try that
[ __ ] i had a terrible idea me and my uh
boy ramses uh
me ramses theo gio and d'angelo were
supposed to do a photo shoot for
this newspaper in arizona called the
write-up back in the day
i remember that
and uh you know matlocks of course so
matlock's uh
[Music]
i don't know if it was his idea ramses
idea to climb the top of camelback
mountain and take pictures on top of the
mountain in our [ __ ] outfits for a
[ __ ] photo shoot it was
one of the worst days of my life
but it's probably some epic pictures
though cool pictures we got them forever
for sure see it's that memory no you're
right though you're right like i i do
think like
most people are trained and they're
autumn i mean everyone's kind of
raised in whatever comfort zone that
they whether it's your parents whether
it's your environment
and
i just think like i've always just kind
of had like a
attitude of like trying to be
uncomfortable
that's it because when i'm uncomfortable
i feel like i get the most out of just
whatever i'm trying to do you know
bootleg kev podcast got to stop things
real quick tell you about our good folks
at blue chew listen fellas if you're
trying to get your dick right you trying
to stay harder everyone wants to be hard
can you stay hard
you know what i mean
if you need some help with your dick is
essentially what i'm trying to say
you need to go to bluechew.com and get
down with uh something that i feel like
is imperative and having yourself a
lovely evening with a lovely young lady
or male whatever you're into if you go
to bluetooth.com you will get a blue
chew it has the same active ingredient
as cialis and his viagra
right but guess what it doesn't have the
awkward doctor visits that's right you
don't got to wait in line at some lobby
to go get you some [ __ ] [ __ ] to get
your dick working and have some awkward
conversation with a nurse and then have
an awkward conversation with a doctor
and then he writes you a prescription
and then you go to the pharmacist and
then it's awkward because you pass them
the prescription and everyone knows
you're picking up dick stuff you know
what i'm saying no blue chew you go to
the website it's all online it gets sent
straight to your house in discrete
packaging in a chewable form
listen your first month free
right now when you go to bluechew.com
and you use the promo code bootleg
that's right you get the first month for
free
bluechew.com promo code
bootleg
thank me later all right go get your
dick together fellas break down um
the alpha what is the alpha male what is
a beta male for people who hear those
two words and don't necessarily aren't
educated as to what that is man yeah so
alpha beta these are greek letters a b
um and in our society or in our culture
the alpha
like alpha
in the the animal kingdom or in humans
is this a more uh
dominant
male a more a leader you know what i'm
saying that's all it is and the betas
are more of the followers you know and i
don't want to get it anything confused
with anybody out there
as saying a alpha is better than a beta
because i'm not i don't think that you
know
um actually
i've been talking about this a lot
lately that
like alpha males are becoming less and
less useful in society you know what i
mean
alpha male is useful for himself and
maybe the people closest to him but
what's better for society is better
males and if you look at society our
society is ran by beta males regardless
of what people think you know um this
country is a democracy i'm saying with a
system of checks and balances so there's
no kings
even a president people when people
really understand
the nature of the government the federal
government the framework of it and all
the state governments and city
governments
the federal government is is maybe a
little bit more powerful than
the royal parliament [ __ ] in london like
the kings and queens you know what i'm
saying like they're they're just there
for pageantry
listen
donald trump when he was in office he
complained all the time about not being
able to get [ __ ] done because it don't
matter you don't you don't run [ __ ] the
presidents don't run [ __ ] well yeah how
it's how it's set up is
um like the checks and balances kind of
at times you know it's crazy because um
i never thought about this but like i
was just talking to somebody about this
last week about like
every four years or eight years some
[ __ ] will start to get done and then and
then whoever gets whoever gets elected
will try to undo whatever the last guy
did which is actually a good thing it's
just a well i guess it depends right
because let's say
you're on the cusp of getting something
historically dope done i don't know what
it might be whatever it's
whatever right something that's going to
help a lot of people free healthcare
whatever it is
then another guy gets elected and then
they undo all it it just feels like a
cycle of like because it is very
cyclical as to which party is in right
it's like it'll be eight years of a
democrat and then it'll be
eight years of george w bush then it's
eight years of obama then trump you know
what i mean so
it just feels like uh a bureaucracy
cycle of like it is and as much as
as ugly as it is and as much as people
are so hot and vitriol about who's in
and who's not this is the best case
scenario for everybody for society in
the world for civilization yeah because
we don't they talk about corruption
voter fraud yes every election is fraud
but that's to be expected
if i was trying to run for president i'm
going to be trying to cheat too like i
want yeah
well i think all that like like you said
every election there's voter fraud yeah
but every election ever is not that's
not what total corruption
total corruption is venezuela is when a
[ __ ] win by 90
you know what i'm saying
you will never find even 55
45 in america it's always a a percentile
or two off and that's perfect people
should be appreciative of that you know
what i'm saying so
yeah everybody hate
for half the country to hate the
president and love the president each
time whichever way is the best case
scenario that's fair you know
yeah i think uh we think of a country
that's like a first world country russia
russia is like a big country that's not
like some [ __ ] third world place it's
very they have mcdonald's they have
starbucks well not anymore apparently
they've gotten all the mcdonald's out
there but if you think about a place
like russia russia is a first world
country but
yeah it's a very
joe biden's not [ __ ] getting people
killed or running against them and
donald trump wasn't getting people
killed or running against him nobody's
afraid of joe biden
i mean
nobody's afraid of joe biden sleepy joe
yeah
i just mean in terms of like
opponents aren't getting each other
murked right you know what i'm saying
exactly it's so
we such [ __ ] babies here we complain
about so much we don't know how good we
have we don't know how good we have it
and people won't know because i didn't
know bro until i started traveling the
world
and i'd be in dope ass places but i'm
like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i won't go back home i
went to so many and then the closest
place i
i almost got a crib in sydney australia
at one point right because
i bet you you were slaying out there
it was nice out there bro the weather
was was dope bunch of iggy azaleas
running around yeah all of that is she
australia yeah okay but the people are
so [ __ ] nice and when you're
traveling different countries when you
go to english-speaking countries it's
just a better vibe you know what i'm
saying right so
it's all like this is kind of dope but
then like when covet happens to see
character comes out in hard times right
so kovit came out right
you're looking at europe looking at
australia these [ __ ] are on
martial law a lot especially in
australia australia was really bad all
that so i was like [ __ ] that we free
here i don't care about people
complaining neighbors snitching on
themselves out there was crazy yeah bro
we and they don't got guns yeah that's
crazy
look i just i just realized this during
the past two years
we're the only country who have a
constitutional right for our citizens to
carry weapons yeah that widespread
everybody got them people don't realize
that they don't know that [ __ ] they're
taking that away from the canadians
right now oh i didn't even know they had
guns
trudeau just uh
banned handguns or is proposing it and i
think [ __ ] that setting up uh some sort
of like turn-in date where you have to
turn in your handguns or something i
don't know if it passed i'm not like
super i just i i just know that like it
was it's being proposed you gotta come
get it from me
yeah and that's the thing with like the
gun violence thing is like i think
i do think that an 18 year old shouldn't
be able to go to the store and buy two
ars without [ __ ] any sort of
conversation or hey what are you
what what's going on why do you need
these guns like there should be some
sort of background check for certain
things but
i also think we have to understand that
we're in america
this is the only place in the world like
this place and unfortunately for the
good for the bad
this is our culture
and our culture is we
have guns and if and there's more guns
here
than people by a whole lot so the
realistic expectation to ban
and i do think like again i think there
should be like comprehensive
background checks for certain weapons
like like what like i think if if if
like that kid in uh you don't you've all
day like he turned 18 and he went to the
store and bought two ar-15s no checks
just wouldn't cop two guns
yeah i mean i don't know if i like that
that extensive background check [ __ ]
because it's like
when does it stop or even or even like
how about a course
how about
like you need a license to have an ar-15
if you want an assault weapon you got to
have a license you got to go through
schooling
like if if i'm if i'm a 16 year old but
that's not the that won't be the route
to the problem because it's not about
how accurate you can shoot it's about
your temperament your personality you
know what i'm saying or if you have any
mental illness and [ __ ] like that
because then the [ __ ] that be
going out doing dumb [ __ ] is not how
proficient yeah and maybe those dumb
[ __ ]
we'll see damn getting that gun
is i'm lazy i like to [ __ ] play call
of duty all day and jerk off in my
parents bedroom
i am not trying to go down to the
[ __ ] gun department and and go
through six hours of of machine gun
class yeah i wouldn't either but i think
this will like but i would do it like i
would go through that for a gun like
because you're a responsible gun owner
like me too but i don't want to have to
i don't want the government telling me i
have to do [ __ ]
i think just certain guns though like i
think if you get a handgun that's that's
something that i think you should be
able to get a handgun and that should
kill a lot of people too i i feel you
you get it you get a clip with a drum
it's got as much rounds as any other
rifle you know what i'm saying here's
the thing bro
when when would it stop if we allow that
it's a slippery slope opens up
the door for tyranny
i'm i mean listen i don't disagree with
that but i just think that there has to
be
a course man like i'm not mad at the
course especially how about this if
you're like under the age of 30 or 25
let's say you're like a 21 year old kid
like you should
we should know you know how to operate
this thing before you get it you know
what if that's the case they should do
the same with law enforcement
i agree shouldn't be it shouldn't be a
21 year old cop no i think i think um
you know the defund of police
conversation is one that is
badly branded i suppose mr brand so i
have a friend that works in government
and she she's a liaison between these
these groups and the government right
and i said why that and she said no this
is not it's not what you think she said
they got to aim high with these
over-the-top uh requests to find some
middle ground to get something done aim
higher so you can get so there's not
really defense they're not defunding the
police they reload reallocating
resources resources which has to happen
but but that doesn't have a ring to it
yeah not for sure but it's it's listen
the conversation though what we're
talking about is for the micro not the
macro yeah what i'm saying so
the people they want to hear over the
top like and you need the public rally
behind you all of that [ __ ] well
people's political stances or just
opinions on most things are just
headline-based
there's absolutely no death to their
opinions and this is the thing about
obviously they just yell whatever tribe
that they're a part of whatever scene
yeah that's talking point at you
and there's no depth to how they feel
it's just this is how i'm supposed to
feel i don't get involved i say [ __ ] red
and blue [ __ ] both sides none of them
give a [ __ ] about us and here's the
thing i'm of the opinion of like groups
of people not voting
let them feel you let them feel your
absence you know what i'm saying if
black people didn't vote in this
election
if black people didn't vote in this
election joe biden would not have even
been to the nominee that part the only
reason that he became the nominee was
because of the south carolina primary
listen they were counting him out it was
bernie's nomination
and then he [ __ ] ran it up in the
south with the older black voters yeah
black people need to divorce themselves
from the democratic party hands down
really like people
is so emotionally attached to this [ __ ]
it's crazy i'm not even
i'm not even saying go be republican not
just but just like just stop being so
blindly loyal to these [ __ ] and
they do they do the worst for black
people
horrible things throughout history it's
been all back well yeah especially like
i mean the clinton era i mean even back
before that like these people are so bad
for black people and they just
what did clinton do i'm going to arsenio
hall show i'm a pander you know what i'm
saying just like trump pandered to the
[ __ ] white supremacists he know white
supremacy he just he knows his base
the problem is is the base of every
political party
is the problem
so if the base of the and this is where
i'm at so like i voted for joe biden
i'm an independent but i just voted for
him just because i was like
the [ __ ] that's being normalized by
trump to me was scary you know what i'm
saying what was that just to me like
his like absolute
first of all he has zero humility but i
just feel like some of the racial
overtones and under undertones he was he
was kind of injecting into society were
just very like i'm like this is
and i i know some people will say well
at least he was blatantly like telling
you how he felt
as opposed to
i mean i think with some of the things
he was doing for sure but what about see
here's the thing
people will take and i'm not and by the
way a trump fan right so i'm not a fan
of nobody
but here's the thing
i'm an objective observer right and i
remember at one point i was like [ __ ]
trump by the way why am i saying that
because everybody's saying that why are
they saying it oh cause he racist what
makes him racist oh the
you remember [ __ ] in virginia all these
good people
guys so let me let me find the video let
me watch it david duke [ __ ] i watched
the [ __ ] right
that speech was taking that clip was
taken out of context first of all the
whole speech probably had 30 thousand
views not many views right it was
interesting but i watched this [ __ ] bro
and this is not how he said that [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying this is what he
said i'm paraphrasing but he said look
there are good people
protesting keeping that part of their
history up and they have the right to
there's good people who feel a certain
way about that [ __ ] it reminds them of
the past and it's that third peacefully
protesting to take it down they have
every right to he was talking about them
when he said and he's right like
i might want to leave this part of
history up i'm a protest i want to take
it down i'm a protest they both have the
right he was talking about that in
particular he said nothing about
like praising these people now here's
the thing i always bring this to people
that say oh he's a racist
i said izzy
because come on there's legislation he
was on a method man album to cal 2000
there's legislation that nobody talks
about
hbcu [ __ ] who's the who's the
like
in the the optics of of united states
who are the most feared
terrorist group or terrorist
organization
since the inception of our country well
the perception would be that it's people
from the middle east but i think i don't
know i'm talking about like from
american born
white people this is klugel's clan yeah
kkk nobody has touched them
they've never been designated as a
terrorist organization trump designated
them as a hate group in a terror
organization
nobody talks about that they got no
press you know what i'm saying and that
that had never been done before right
nobody touched it yeah you know what i'm
saying and you know uh
obama biting they backed
uh biden's um mentor was a he was in the
clan he got out later in his life
i forget the guy's name that was wrong
yeah cause you're dying [ __ ] but
you know what i'm saying so it's like
it people gotta even like the george
floyd thing man like
like taking lives is [ __ ] up right
but
why was that given to us when it was
given to us
it wasn't given to us when it happened
you know i'm saying
the public outcry this this [ __ ] was
months after that [ __ ] happened you know
what i'm saying so it's like they're
tugging at y'all our emotions are our
hearts you know what i'm saying with
fear with terror with anger you know
what i'm saying and people are just
listening and marketing like i'm a
marketer in essence and we're able to
predict people's behavior human behavior
that's how we're able to
[ __ ] order inventory do this do that
right
politics is no different than marketing
you know what i'm saying
and human behavior is very predictable
especially when it comes to emotional
things you know they're able to to guide
people where they want to go by making a
map or press the map button yeah i mean
and the media has so much to do with
that too right
it's like yo like if you're
think about
how much covert was just being [ __ ]
stuffed down our throats listen and how
much
it was like
this is this is the there's only one way
to feel about this or you're a piece of
[ __ ] murderer no it's nothing it's fine
now well how about this
during that period of time you're
talking about after george floyd was
murdered and obviously everyone was
rightfully outraged
the covet [ __ ] went away
nobody was talking about covert anymore
it was like nah this is th this is this
is where the eyes are right now we're
gonna put these we're gonna put all this
[ __ ] on tv because
you know this is where it's at
here's the thing bro
covered went away too by the way when
ukraine yeah
got into you know the war is still going
on fighting i don't even [ __ ] with what
they say about that [ __ ] like
oh they're ukraine smashing russia
russia is the bad guy like all right in
my business you i'm saying
anyway
look
life is fair
the universal laws
that we all follow without knowing works
out you know what i'm saying the only
thing that i see is unfair and maybe i
just don't understand is like when
children are born into shitty situations
or born deformed and [ __ ] like that's
the only thing i see is not fair but
other than that [ __ ] is fair and
everything balances out you know
all right so early we mentioned um like
maybe the government would give people
health care so let's say there's people
that like man we should have free health
care
you can get free health care you know
what i'm saying
every socialist thing that people want
that we don't they don't think we can
have you could do every capitalist thing
every
government system is here in america in
some capacity you know what i'm saying
everything however you want to live you
can live you know what i'm saying listen
i personally lived
as a ghost most my life until 2014
not on the map i was i was a special ops
from the hood
until i was ready to to present myself
and pay taxes and do all the regular
[ __ ] right so anybody can nestle into
any crevice they want to and live a good
life you know what i'm saying i do think
that there are certain
people get born into certain situations
that
i mean do make [ __ ] harder man you know
what i mean like if you if you're if
you're born into a yeah i'm i mean
but bro you know like i know typically
people who are born into hard times are
[ __ ] stronger and they most of the
time this story is way you're right
you're right
the minority of those that we hear about
but i think the more of the the more
probably common thing
is that those people end up having
shitty lives because they had no
role models in their house or maybe
their mom was addicted to drugs or maybe
they were born
and their mom was using drugs while they
were you know i just think that like
i do i do think like they're
yes
if you're built like you and me or
people that we know and you have a
certain mindset you're going to get
through whatever
but
there's just this not everyone's built
that way but that's
it can't be you know what i'm saying no
no you're right it can't be and so what
i was saying like when we were talking
about this you brought up social [ __ ] i
do think like if you're a
single mom
and
life has presented you with you had
three or four kids
and you don't have an education for your
decisions i mean yeah those were your
decisions these are your kids there's
your responsibilities at the same time
if you don't have uh
a resume or you don't have a lot of
qualifications to get you a real solid
gig
um
i mean some of these jobs man
are
like the minimum wage in some of these
places is crazy like you like can you
imagine the national minimum it sounds
crazy to think that the national minimum
wage is seven dollars and sixty cents
it's hilarious because it's
disrespectful it should be you would
think it'd be at least 10 bucks but we
got to look at this too
here in california is what
yeah i don't know like 12 13 i think
it's 12 bucks so more expensive places
it's adjusted listen i think it's still
all fair i think everything's fair look
if you don't want a minimum wage job
qualify yourself for a job that pays
more is that simple you're right you're
right so i don't really i don't
increase your market your market
viability exactly i feel you 100
but also i have a different perspective
on fair right right
life ain't fair i don't expect it to be
you know i'm saying i think everything's
universally fair right i think that we
are governed by certain laws that just
is entropy is
cause and effect is a decision is your
destiny all of that [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying so that makes it fair like
yeah that's what happens this can be
measured you know what i'm saying if i
if i jog a lot i increase my lung
capacity and i can absorb breathing
better right last longer cardio [ __ ] so
it's in that sense it's fair but when we
when we start talking about morals and
ethics is not fair it's not yeah no for
sure and and like there is a truth in
the
term like there's no excuses because if
you are that mom who has two full-time
jobs
and you're [ __ ] just barely hanging
on
like figure out the 60 minutes of the
day where you read a book and pick up a
new skill if you're on the bus or you're
driving home
have youtube playing teach you a new
skill but here's the thing we gotta we
gotta
people gotta recalibrate
like
what is
success to them you know what i'm saying
because if you're making less money
decrease your your overhead you know
what i'm saying and then find happiness
in other things outside of what
everybody else got be willing to eat
[ __ ] for a little bit
i don't even listen we human beings have
such a powerful [ __ ] attribute
a thing that changes
you me anybody who can shift the
universe with our perspective
and our perception of things right
so
if you're making
what most would consider poverty type
income right
you adjust your perspective and find
happiness in other things right it
you'll probably be happier than people
with a lot of money right because look
i have a lot of money i make a lot of i
have a lot of [ __ ] going on but
happiness don't come with all that [ __ ]
sorry just get the tv right
sorry yeah happiness don't come
inherently with money and success this
is true man i tell people all the time i
deal with depression like the next
person so
it and when i get recalibrate and find
happiness it's not in a woman it's not
in my homies not even in my children
it's here
and here you know what i'm saying it's
the things that i got to work on in my
own mind
me recalibrating perceptions and [ __ ]
like that to readjust and find like
beauty in different things
because look bro i used to like have
like four cars two cars in this state
cars in this state and it's down the
third and then one day i'm looking at
this [ __ ] nerd in the indus in my
industry who i don't respect who's a
goober
all these cars and these funny outfits
and [ __ ] i'm like i don't ever want to
look like this [ __ ] like i don't
ever want to be confused
with anybody to be somebody like him
and i was like and i used to have to
have xyz i had to have this i had to
have that right i got rid of all of that
[ __ ] and i'm fine i got one card at a
time that's all i can drive anyway you
know what i'm saying and i'm cool with
that [ __ ] bro so and look uh last year
i was like [ __ ] i'm gonna get back on my
car [ __ ]
and i'm like
why am i doing this
not for yourself it wasn't for me at all
yeah i'm saying so i got rid of that
[ __ ] so and went back to what made what
i'm content with
i have a lot of friends that got a bunch
of cars that's fine
i don't knock it
i think it's dope i like cars but i
don't want that i want because when you
have a lot of things there's a lot of
effort in you keeping them
maintaining them maintaining them and
keeping people from taking it takes from
your bandwidth take sure it does
the littlest mental space is just a
thing that's going to deteriorate bro
trust me i'm the i am the i
dude
you're talk you're preaching to the
choir
i can afford
a lot of cars right i don't give a [ __ ]
i have a paid off car
it runs i got a [ __ ] suv it's
got 200 000 miles on it until that [ __ ]
stops working i've been so tempted to
get like a [ __ ] g-wagon or something
the piece you have not worrying about
putting a hundred thousand on a car
right and like also like i just bought a
house and
um
you know
that's something that i'm like okay i'll
i'll put money up for that because i
have two kids i got my wife you know
what i mean i'm like
yeah i'm gonna get a crib but like what
is me buying a car my car is [ __ ]
straight it runs it's got ac
everything's fine it's a great car fits
my family in it my wife has her car
everything's paid off like
i was like what am i if i buy a car
i would rather take that money and like
literally put it into a new camera or
just something else something that's
going to generate me income as opposed
to like
some sort of piece of social equity that
i'm literally buying because i'm
personally content with the car i have
but i'm really getting this car so when
i people look at me differently yeah
people who don't give a [ __ ] about you
i'm not a car enthusiast right so if
it's not like i'm some [ __ ] you know
meathead who like loves engines and [ __ ]
i don't i don't dude i could i am i'm a
media i love ninjas but i have that [ __ ]
in control and check that [ __ ] don't
control me you know right and listen i
ain't gonna lie role so it's time that i
am out of control
when it comes to like whips and [ __ ]
everyone's like i'll be sitting there
calculating like damn okay i i remember
uh i had one car in mind on this budget
i get this it's next to the newest
version of that car and i'm like it's
ooh
eighty thousand dollar hundred thousand
dollar prices something crazy right
right and i'm just doing the math in my
head i'm like how can i make that more
i'm saying he's like the guy's right
here i'm looking at the car seat i want
this car like a crackhead like yeah i'm
gonna get this car i want this car i'm
gonna come back tomorrow with her back
like i'm like what's what the you know
what snapped me out of that that day
like later on that day
it was around it was october
2021 and we went to uh horror nights
halloween horror nights universal yeah
and we took shrooms and mdma right oh
wow that sounds like a great [ __ ]
night and it just brought me to my
reality like why would you do that
that's stupid you don't need that bro i
was stuck on i'm buying that card
tomorrow give a [ __ ] i make more money
kind of like when i was hustling
i can get it back
i mean i think that that is also a
natural human like instinct it's a
weakness it's a dude i've been there
where i've been you know
dude on the smallest level
my wife was buying me a grill for a
father's day this past weekend a group
no a grill to cook on i'm about to buy
girl because i got because i got i got i
got a new crib right so she's like yeah
i want to get you a grill
and then i realize that there's all
these types of grills there's like a
wood pellet grill and then there's a
flat top grill
and i was like i want both so you buy me
one and i wasn't even interested in
grills before yeah but i was like oh
[ __ ] yeah i need both so i just buy one
and then you buy one as my gift and now
i got two grills on my [ __ ] house
i don't know i was fine without a single
grill
[ __ ] but now i could cook i could cook
all kinds of [ __ ] i i started putting in
perspective how much money i spent on
[ __ ]
you know i'm saying stuff i spent more
money like last year i spent more money
on things
than most people would make in a year or
two you know what i'm saying just that
money's poof gone
you know what i'm saying so
a grill i'll do that extra girl i do
fordham [ __ ] i ain't buying all these
cars and [ __ ] and yeah and the other
thing is is like if you're gonna [ __ ]
off money [ __ ] it off on memories man
yeah like go on a trip with the kids you
know like go to go do some [ __ ] that you
that that's
worth it right right but but once again
it's your perspective and what's
important to you yeah and listen people
are [ __ ] stressed i heard kevin said
kevin gates said on you
with you he said that
uh
what did he say
that he was comparing his life to
people's
highlight reels on instagram yeah and
it's like so that's a social media [ __ ]
[ __ ] people's lives
[ __ ] your life
not in a bad way but i don't yeah your
life hey i'm not you you ain't me i know
you don't care about my life yeah i'm
saying
so i really don't care about what y'all
do you know i mean i got a good homie of
mine um who just broke up with this girl
and i was like you y'all broke up and he
was like yeah like it's done and i was
like
they've been together for a long time
you know
maybe three or four years
and on social media they look like
the happiest i was like bro what he's
like bro
the [ __ ] you don't see is this [ __ ] on
social media we've been miserable for a
long time and i'm like damn like you
could have [ __ ] fooled me man yeah
everybody put the best
look for social media i keep it 100 like
social media is a business it's a tool
it's a tool for me it's not my real life
it isn't one tiny sliver it's a piece of
your life it's that's it it's not like
my happiness and my this is none of that
[ __ ] i'm not
why do i need to report to people about
my relationships and none of that [ __ ]
right it's someone's business there's a
means for me to make make income and
y'all are consuming it i want to give
you how cool [ __ ] that i like that's it
you know what i'm saying but you can
guide people wherever you want to
and yeah people do that
it's weird to me that people that spend
so much time on there just expressing
their life showing their life just to be
showing it yeah without no without no
desired outcomes that is also some some
people's whole business model is that
if it's a business model fine yeah
you're making money but there's a lot
that ain't most aren't
that's true most aren't those people are
just volunteering their their misery for
us well they they're they're giving
is it's a it's a cycle
they're offering all of their
information their details and their
their their likes and dislikes
for
uh producers
to again to identify who they can market
market towards yeah yeah like what pages
do you like what did you like what were
you looking at on the internet because
when you open up the next app there's
going to be an ad for it 100 so many
[ __ ]
i was literally looking up grill ads
like grill videos and now dude every
time i open my [ __ ] phone it's an ad
from traeger oh yeah
i'm like jesus that's what's up so your
supplements um kind of break down to me
because i like shrooms as well obviously
you talked about by the way was that a
good experience halloween horror nights
on mdma and shrooms
yeah it was cool but
like for me
me being on psychedelics i much rather
be chilling hmm yeah you'd right you
would because that's a lot universal
studios in l.a yeah they're running out
of staircases they're running out and
[ __ ]
that's a brave [ __ ] that's a brave
choice
it doesn't that it just calms me real
heavy
it's like calm down bro like running out
trying to scare people like so it take
it it kind of inhibits the the amygdala
to it to an extent to where you don't
really have fear so like was everyone on
the on your level that you went with no
i'm always on the highest level because
i need a lot you know what i'm saying
but everybody was on a level you know
but i find more enjoyment like in small
social settings on psychedelics what's
your like go-to shroom strain
um i don't really have one i'll do
chocolates oh the chocolate i got i got
gummy spray i got a gummy company okay
oh dope yeah i [ __ ] with it i i prefer
like mdma on some social [ __ ] yeah you
know i've never done mdma um it's the
best
i hear that it's great but i'm always
like worried about like uh
you know i grew up my whole family is a
bunch of drug addicts you know so
um anything that's like anything i know
and i know there's versions of it that
aren't in pill form but anything that's
like a pill i just freaked out about all
right so what i do is a hard pressed
pill
but
my source i get a pure mdma do you test
it nah so i bought a whole kit
uh a spectrometer all that [ __ ] but
excuse me that's just complicated you
got to have every drug that you want to
test it against to be able to test it i
don't know where to get heroin or meth
and none of that [ __ ] so
my guy is legit so
i'd just be worried about fentanyl
business yeah no my guy's legit so
my
so there's people who you know molly
ecstasy mdma mdma is the active
ingredient
molly i think is cut with we all say
molly for mdma but but
is mdma and heroin
and then ecstasy is mdma and meth you
know what i'm saying so molly heroin is
supposed to be way better than mdma but
you're gonna have some side effects and
[ __ ] like that and probably withdrawals
i've never had any of that so mdma
you just happy as [ __ ] i'm saying
the worst thing is you can't bust yams
in when you're smashing
um you wake up fine i go to the gym in
the morning like if i party i gotta get
up early and go to the gym you know what
i'm saying it's funny that you said what
you just said because
ada south side from 808 mafi was talking
about doing mdma
and then not getting [ __ ]
and then i was like well
well do you jerk off he's like yeah i
was like is it a better jerk it's like
it's not a better jerk but it is a
longer jerk
that's bizarre
i was like all right
but
uh but now but
mdma but the best that i've taken i
haven't had in a long time is lsd
like surgical yeah
it so that's more visual like heavy
visual right
no
not necessarily well this is what it
does so
if so all of the classic psychedelics
bind to the two-way serotonin receptor
they all do the same thing
but
lsd binds
more perfect than serotonin you feel me
okay so
it's just a it's a longer experience and
it's just
now visually is like everything like i
wear glasses i got my glasses on now
because i have sensitive eyes my other
glasses in the car
and they're tinted but
uh my vision is perfectly hd 4k 8k on
lsd you just literally see better for
one
um
the most i've seen visually is just
distortions
but not like anything that wasn't there
yeah i did see one time so one time i
did do a heroic dose right which is of
what lsd lsd
that's a hero dose is like for people
who don't know that's like if you want
to change your life it's very
transformative yeah you did it here so
how much is that i don't even know what
the measurement is but i did an entire
dropper where you only do a little
bubble right you do like the little tab
and then
you did a whole drop you could do the
tabs which is the easiest way to measure
it or liquid
which you're supposed to dilute and then
do it like that but i never diluted it
but i knew how to get it enough but this
one one day i did the whole drop so what
happened
um the only thing i seen visually was
the camera melting
but i'm sitting there looking at like i
know that it's not melting but it's
[ __ ] crazy that it looks like it's
melting you know what i'm saying
but other than that um
it was just like it's very
transformative in a sense that what it
does is
now when you take this big dose it's not
euphoric like when you take a hit you
know what i'm saying
so that big dose it tells it your soul
you know i mean so things that are on
your heart it magnifies it
so if it's something if you got some
demons you got to face that [ __ ]
so i faced mine and it was just like a
relationship with a friend that i needed
to fix you know what i'm saying and you
have a sense of urgency to work on it
how long did that last
the the
day yeah
the whole like
15 hours or so 12. i've always i i've
i've heard people doing uh hero's dose
on psilocybin i can't imagine how you
could do that i think you have to eat so
many i think it's nasty as mushrooms
it's
i don't three-eighths
i've eaten handfuls of mushrooms and
never even come close to and then you
always hear people um talk about like
ayahuasca and dmt being yeah those are
way different so dmt i will blast you
off for like 10 minutes yeah but you're
like not there you lose track of time
yeah your eyes are rolling in the back
of your head one of my best friends to
dmt said that
he got a job
was in a new relationship
and lived like six months of life
in 20 minutes
yeah you you're you're people think that
they're gone for a long time
have you done that i've done dmt but i
never blast it off okay so you got to
smoke it i smoked you got a free basic
vape yeah the pen the pen [ __ ] yeah it's
not the way i hear yeah but it knocks it
like one year on my birthday i did lsd
um
shrooms
and i was puffing a dmt pen
now it was a good fun night but it
sounds like it wasn't crazy but just
taking a hit of lsd is very euphoric
it's the best you could sit there and do
nothing and just be chilling like man
this is good i'm having a good time like
listening to music and [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying on on the vape no no on
a a hit of lsd oh okay okay like a like
a normal a normal lsd
yeah a normal level so so so one night
um everybody came over for a fight and
um i had taken shrooms and lsd everybody
else just took shrooms
and so i'm i'm good i can't wait for
everybody to leave and i lay down and i
put on i've been wanting to watch
that lemonade album
uh the all the videos from beyonce
yeah i take it it takes me a long time
to get into [ __ ] i don't want to watch
[ __ ] when everybody talking about it
yeah i'm saying but that [ __ ] been
sitting in my head for years this night
i watched it
every [ __ ] video and i was like this
is f i respect this woman and then i
watched jay-z's 44-4 all his videos it
was a response to that
i'm like wow i was blown a [ __ ] way
and then i watched a nice documentary
you know what i'm saying yeah all right
man he's such a dope dude like it just
you just enjoy [ __ ]
you you ain't rushing like i can't sit
and watch no a bunch of videos back to
back you know what i'm saying
but on that i i watched and i had the
time of my life and i gained a newfound
respect for all three of them i always
loved them but it was a different thing
and i was so inspired you know i mean
definitely i do feel like um
you like i i discovered this band called
tame impala
on shrooms
it's one guy they sounds real for me so
this guy is headlined coachella like uh
it's one dude who plays all the
instruments it's crazy
but uh i was just uh i was in joshua
tree and airbnb and uh
i don't even know how it came on i think
i searched like shroom music or
something because i ate a lot and i was
in a [ __ ] hot tub under the stars and
i was like oh this is the best song i've
ever heard in my life who is this right
right right there's some music that hits
so do you see do you see [ __ ] when you
take nah nah i think i just really just
get stuck like in my thoughts
in a good way and in a bad way but i
have i take that back
i took a bunch of edibles
and i ate shrooms and i got drunk as
[ __ ] and austin me and freddie gibbs are
out there he did the joe rogan podcast
and um
uh you know i'm a big joe rogan fan so
uh
we ended up hanging out with him again
at night uh upstairs at uh
anton's comedy club
and i had these shroom chocolates
and i was like yo joe
like you're the reason why loki i got
interested in the shrooms he's like so
it's only right i'm gonna eat these in
front of you all right so me and me and
freddie split the candy bar joe didn't
eat no he was like no i got a plan for
this [ __ ] man he's like i just don't i
just don't [ __ ] he's like it's a
tuesday night it was a tuesday night
it's a bummer yeah it was kind of a
bummer but uh he was cool as [ __ ] but
um so i i was already off of [ __ ]
edibles
shit-faced drunk and i ate a bunch of
shrooms um i split the bar with fred and
then we went out bar hopping
and and i feel like every time i get
super [ __ ] up on psychedelics and i go
out all the wild [ __ ] that would happen
to somebody
in real life
that would suck if you were tripping
always happens to me
so like there was this chick at this bar
on sixth in austin who was dancing for
like 30 minutes straight craziest cardio
i've ever seen on a human being she must
have been on some [ __ ] oh no she turned
around
and her face was it you know like it was
like pixelated like it was censored it's
like it was censored on cops like you
know like back in there you see you
watch cops and they
her face was censored yeah
like it was just that's weird bro i had
so that day well i
took that heroic dose
he was with me you know andre berto the
boxer he was with me and then my old
assistant
and bro
i would think she's the most righteous
person here but her face was weird as
[ __ ] and nobody else's face was
i like hey you you good i'm looking at
you like she's looking at me like i
can't even tell you what was wrong with
it but there's something wrong with this
like her normal cute voice yeah right
i'm fine yep
i see you sure i said come here real
quick i'm trying to see
and it's the same as she's getting
closer i just like had to turn go
somewhere i even went and looked at
myself in the mirror okay they say don't
look at yourself you don't freak out
i'm normal
but only her face
and she's a sweet i don't know what the
significance of that was you know what i
mean
cause she's not a bad person she's a
great person not your assistant anymore
nah only because she moved on to bigger
i thought that's where the story was
going i thought you're gonna be like her
face was melting and three weeks later i
found out she was stealing from me nah
nah never none of that she she was a
like she's a good friend of mine you
know that's tough but um but i never
told her that [ __ ] i won't tell her that
yeah well she'll watch this she took lsd
like one time everybody in my office we
all took it
like when we found out about it and said
cause you know you think you can't work
but you work better you know what i'm
saying so we all took it and she freaked
out
didn't work for her
i sat where i had a perfect high or
whatever you call it perfect but i had
to tend to her for like six hours well i
think it's it it is one of the like rare
things like psychedelics is like really
a person-to-person basis man yeah cause
my wife will eat like a lot and not
barely feel anything and i'll eat the
same amount and i'll be [ __ ]
sunk yeah i'll be in the sunken place
speaking of rogan i went to see him at
irvine improv
um
and i ate two chocolate bars right
and he was [ __ ] hilarious i felt like
he was on strange too
you know what i'm saying i mean we're
gonna abide
um but this is weird
he it was like not him
everybody that came on stage looked
[ __ ] bizarre [ __ ]
right and he was like this is not this
is him but it's not
the texture of his skin was weird
because you know he's kind of short and
like like a like a short caveman by very
much yeah but it was like intensified
it's crazy how short he is like when you
actually meet him and you don't realize
like oh he's a short dude like he's
right
i mean he's [ __ ] built like a [ __ ]
tree you know but i seen him maybe a
month later sober
look like normal joe rogan
have you ever talked to him about maybe
going on the show or anything no i don't
i don't know i we have somebody a couple
people mutual
uh friends
but now i haven't had a i would love to
one day everybody be like you like the
black little rogan i take that as a
compliment but i don't have a reason
right now you know what i'm saying if
it's a big project i have coming out or
whatever
maybe you drop a book or a yeah
documentary or yeah
these are all things that i'm working on
so then i'll play that card but i want
to do it just to do it i mean i would if
we could just keep rocking you know i'm
saying because i [ __ ] with him hard you
know what i'm saying i saw uh you had a
bench press competition with bradley
martin yeah yeah um who's also a big
youtuber yeah that's the only um
yeah what what's your like how's he as a
dude because i always see him like on
what steve will do it and the knelt boys
and [ __ ] he's solid he saw it with me
bro i know he's got a really dope gym in
the valley yeah he um we was cool
lured back in the day
um but you know i just did his podcast
like last week and i just told him some
real [ __ ] on the podcast i said yeah man
we cool but i felt like you kind of like
used me a little bit
like because my my channel was up he
didn't even have a channel and i was
popping and i seen he went to me for a
while then he went to this one and that
one you know what i'm saying which the
knuck boys really [ __ ] yeah and i
haven't seen them a lot yeah i had to
say this i had to to
say it's not that you did anything wrong
you identified what was going to be
um beneficial for your acceleration in
the space
that's fine it's not wrong with that i
just don't do that like
my relationships with people are genuine
you know what i'm saying
and
so that just kind of felt weird you know
what i'm saying unfortunately a lot of
people are like that man yeah he took it
well
um we
we talked about we good we solid that's
my guy you know what i'm saying i got a
love for him i'm proud of him he's doing
his thing
um but yeah but he's solid bro he's
solid he's one thing that was dope about
him when he came around back then it was
like
it was so many people that wanted to
like come get him videos and [ __ ] right
i'm like all right well come get down
with us because we going to hell and
back
and [ __ ] will come up late to
try to be in part of it
and i'll be telling my videos like don't
have this [ __ ] in there
just turn the camera off when he's doing
this [ __ ] because like nah you do all of
this [ __ ] with us
you ain't got to be as strong but
putting the effort you know i'm saying
there was a guy i remember a guy
because
every i don't really do anymore but
people will
fly in and pay 2 grand to train with me
[ __ ] like that and be in the video
and i remember a guy quit like first two
exercises right really yeah
and then but i felt like he just wanted
to get his picture with me and all that
[ __ ] yeah like he met you he hung out he
got okay i get it then he was like yo
how can i get down with the squad i was
like
my [ __ ] you quit like
that's not what i do like what are you
talking about you know what i'm saying
i'm so pure everything i do
it's just weird when people are on that
kind of [ __ ] around me it's like you
didn't know [ __ ] but and i just
feel like everybody's pure you know i'm
saying
but most people aren't
hey we got to stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our family our
good folks at odd socks you see me look
these are the odd socks basics on my
skinny white [ __ ] legs
i love odd socks go to
oddssocksofficial.com
you're going to get 20 off at checkout
if you use the promo code bootleg kev
that's one word bootleg kev now they got
odd socks which are great my favorites
are the basics they also you know you
got the license one these are the
twizzlers these are baywatch socks but
then you got the basics now these are
what these are just the plain boys man
they're so comfy all right i always got
the white basics the black basics on and
i always got odd socks underwear on too
they got the draws all right so what are
you doing go to oddssocksofficial.com
use the promo code
bootslag kev save 20
off check out these [ __ ] draws
kool-aid
underwear ladies and gentlemen what are
we doing
oddssoxofficial.com bootleg kev is the
promo code save 20 off right now let's
get back to the interview are you still
eating only one time a day
um
what is like
because you know some people uh do the
keto thing some people are very vegan
you know
what would be in your opinion kind of
like
obviously you're an expert in terms of
bodybuilding health
exercise all that what
is do you think is the best diet
it would depend on that individual it
would depend on
what you can sustain what's sustainable
for you you know what i'm saying
it would depend on what works for your
body you know what i'm saying
it's a it's a it's so many variables i
would never say this is the way for
everybody
yeah it feels like a diet diet thing is
kind of like a
not one size fits all it's not right
it's not and it's not rocket science
either you know what i mean there's a
lot of people in the space that over
complicates the information for people
so they feel like they need to be with
these people
i'm not doing that at all i've never
done that so
um i'll communicate the information in a
very digestible way
because that's how i need it to me you
know i'm saying i ask a lot of questions
when i'm trying to understand something
so i think like that when i'm trying to
educate people on certain things
in
return they kind of stay with you anyway
because they [ __ ] with you they respect
you they know that you're giving them
good information so
yeah i never scare people with
information you know unless they're
unhealthy i'm like you're gonna die
right right right you know when you say
you eat once a day it's one meal a day
like will you have a protein shake will
you
have a pre-workout one meal a day like
today i had a beef jerky and some piece
of cheese on the way up here i was just
hungry not a meal not a meal i have a
meal probably when we leave here or get
back to oc
um but yeah
sometimes i do have a protein shake
sometimes i have a shake around the time
of my meal
but it's just one meal you know what i'm
saying and the reason i do it is for
like
the body our bodies
first of all there's two killers
there's two epidemics right in this
country there's not covet there's heart
disease and type 2 diabetes right and
both of them
if
if heart disease and
diabetes is a bullet food is the gun you
know what i'm saying of course we get it
by what by how much we eat and the [ __ ]
that we eat right
so
i i fast like i do a fast once a week
every wednesday 24 hour fast but i've
always been so so every wednesday
you're fasting correct okay so but i
fasted a lot throughout the years right
um i'm muslim not super religious but
it's still in the cultures i'm just used
to it you know what i'm saying but i i
kind of came with my own reasons for
fasting outside of health purposes but
the health purposes is you're giving
your digestive system a break right
you're giving your brain a break because
people don't realize that 40 of the food
or the energy that you put in your body
is being used up by your brain it's
crazy the brain is an expensive piece of
real estate and it's not the biggest you
know what i mean
so
pound for pound your brain's eating the
most using most of the energy that
you're using you're putting your body
now
with that
it's slowing down different mechanisms
in the body so
if you got a little virus little
infection
your immune system is not working as
properly if you always full of food
because you have to digest that [ __ ]
with digestion it's like one two it's
like four or five different stages of
digestion so that's so much work that
your brain got to do and your body got
to produce that's why people get tired
when they eat yeah i mean for sure so
for me me being a high octane person
always on a go with a lot of [ __ ] to do
i want to be at my optimal levels at all
times you're not optimized when you're
full of food you're not
you know our ancestors when they were
hunters and gatherers the [ __ ]
ate a couple times a week let alone a
day you know i mean and when they went
out and hunted for food or or searched
the forage for food or had to track a
[ __ ] elk for miles they did on an
empty stomach
on an empty stomach you have a
heightened sense of awareness and
alertness you have more energy all of
these things this is necessary
in evolutionary biology because we have
to survive you know i mean
it doesn't you get you you get a dump of
uh pleasure sensors when you eat
so you're not trying to hustle you're
not trying to get out of course you eat
you chill you relax you know it's a
reward so you can go and do it again
when it's necessary
so but when you're not the it feels
uncomfortable but you're operating
better now for me
i shift my perspective where i
recalibrate my thinking so
i'm not uncomfortable when i'm not
eating i'm saying i'm actually more
comfortable because everybody else is
tripping out about having to find food
you know what i'm saying and i don't
need it right
and
you know just you know my brain i just
think more clear i make better decisions
you know i don't have that brain fog
when i eat too much like if i a weekend
i f just go hard i got brain fog on
monday i'm saying um a lot will you do
that like a once once a week at least
just go in not really because you
already know you know people have their
cheat day maybe it's once a month once a
week yeah it's such a setback for me so
here's another thing bro i have a
different relationship with food
i don't look at food is not a
pleasurable thing for me i
it tastes good when i eat it
but i'm not i don't associate like
you're like a foodie nah i'm not at all
food is just a means when it's just fuel
for my body that's it
you put gas i don't like gas but i gotta
put it in my car to drive it
it's the same relationship with food 100
even if i go out nice restaurant i
barely eat i'm drinking videos and
having fun i'm there for the vibes i
might eat a little salad just something
when i eat i'm i'm i'm not motivated
when i eat i want to keep my feet up but
i mean obviously you're a big guy you
have a a lifestyle that is
burns a lot of energy so do you get i
mean you obviously have a big meal once
a day and then yeah the protein shake
well my meals at the end of the day
so
um when you don't eat as often you have
better protein synthesis right so that
means you have a better mechanism of
your body breaking down proteins
carbs and fats and
shuttling it to the right places that
you actually need it's no excess right
so
people actually build muscle better when
they eat less you know what i mean
now what you're used to seeing is people
eating five six times a day so they're
going to build a lot of muscle
regardless
and a lot of fat too so
but lots of chips yeah [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] that's crazy but sorry my friend
over there is a vegetarian and all he
does is he [ __ ] noodles chips and
cheese pizza
worst diet ever
so anyway but yeah so yeah um and then
fasting just fasting in general like
your body reaches a it does this thing
called autophagy and what it does is
it's like
it's like a starvation mode right and it
starts cleaning out all the dead cells
you know what i'm saying it's a
regenerative thing that i do once a week
you know and i'm not sure if i reach
autophagy during the like during that
one day period yeah no i know i do it in
a one-day period but i'm not sure if i
do it in my one day throughout the day
once a day like one more day
and i've slowed down my metabolism so
you always hear fast metabolism that's
healthy it's no healthy or unhealthy
metabolism it's just efficient or
inefficient
a fast metabolism is actually an
inefficient metabolism and if you look
at across the [ __ ] animal kingdom the
animals that eat the most live the
shortest years you know i mean big cats
you know the predators
um animals that live the longest i mean
there's a predators too but they eat
very few times like crocodiles sharks
[ __ ] sharks
live like 500 years a greenland shark
lived 500 years they have no reason to
die you know what i'm saying yeah
turtles don't eat [ __ ] and it could be
100 years old right
they eat once a year right once every x
amount of months you know what i'm
saying so um but they have extremely
slow metabolisms and you would you get
that by eating less it's simple
now if someone eats a lot and have a
slow metabolism that's a problem if
they're fat yeah or if somebody eat once
a day and have a fast metabolism it's
just not going to work
right so if you have a faster metabolism
but you slow it down or speed it up
depending on how you eat um my [ __ ] used
to be
like rapid fast when i ate a lot
but um so so i know like my size would
it would seem like it's how is it likely
i can be
2 15 220 on one meal a day i used to be
250 i'm saying i'm not eating a lot
i'm saying so
that ain't healthy even though i looked
great i got my blood work i was trending
towards being pre-diabetic
250 is 250 you don't give a [ __ ] if it's
muscles or not you know what i'm saying
and i was eating
[ __ ] every two three hours you know
what i'm saying spiking insulin becoming
insulin resistant that's how we get
diabetes
so i slowed that [ __ ] down um just took
matters into my own hands
i started doing going back to one meal a
day because i used to do a long time ago
wow yeah what would you say like uh
your routine do you have a routine every
day or does it change because you're
obviously a busy guy you record con you
record content but is there like a i'm
working out during these hours uh i have
my protein shake after you do a protein
shake right after your workout or it
depends on how i feel so i do have a
routine and yeah there are some
variations like say if i come out to la
or whatever but typically i'm i'm at the
gym at 7 30 well i get up around
5 30 5 o'clock i wake up i'm out to bed
5 30 5 45 i meditate first thing in the
morning um and then i'll i'll either sit
and like read or i'll play something and
lay back down like an audio book or
something or a video i want to learn
about
and then i'm out the door
um train
and then my little crew that we all
train together early and then we go sit
in asana and just talk talk [ __ ]
whatever
and then from there home shower get
dressed and i'm at the office i'm either
shooting content or we're in meetings or
phone calls just handling my [ __ ] during
the day
and i'm usually there until about six
seven um
it depends on what i'm working on
sometimes i'll
work from home if i don't have to shoot
something
um and yeah and then at the end of the
day kids or
my own little time [ __ ] like that what
are some i've seen you train with
rappers uh like jim jones in miami
who are some of the artists that you've
trained with uh that could hang with you
a bit
with effort jim jones jim yeah he seems
to take it very serious in terms of just
100 yeah
jimmy would be out partying he come
balance that [ __ ] out in the gym yeah
rocks he a legit rock star yeah but he
he stay on if jimmy wasn't training the
way he do he'd probably be very
unhealthy and look like [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying yeah he's a beast on
both ends yeah he's a beast bro he i
respect the hell out of jim jones it
takes a lot to be a rock star because
there's effort in that he's a rock star
bro yeah but he's he's that guy and then
on top of that to still have the
discipline or find the energy to get up
and hit the gym you have to you have to
or you're going to die
on uh uh unfunded death you know what
i'm saying
we kill ourselves with the [ __ ] that we
do for fun
so you're trying to balance it out with
training and trying to eat right you
know
yeah you were saying that uh do you
think because i i do think that uh
like we said earlier about diets like
it's a not a one-size-fits-all thing do
you think there's
negative drawbacks to people who
cut meat and animal products out of
their diet
yeah i mean there can be a deficiency in
a lot of different um nutrients iron
protein like you name it however there's
supplementation there's other ways to
get these things like if you're taking
supplements you can probably go to like
gnc and find stuff to kind of substitute
yeah this way's around it but
i think like it's all about balance
because i ate a vegan diet for a couple
years oh you did yeah but i didn't think
it was necessary i wanted to try it just
to see and it got it was easy right
um but i don't think i like meat so you
know i love it something like a steak
or or big fillet salmon blackness salmon
yeah it's cooked the right way cooked
the right way exactly
yeah
salmon's got to be prepared right yeah
otherwise it's like it's yeah but uh
what is obviously you have the
supplement line mm-hmm where can people
find that i know it's online but is it
your story ambrosia collector.com or at
all the vitamin shops about a thousand
stores all throughout the country so
that's a yeah that's a big look are you
trying to get in gnc and
no not really they don't have the best
terms and i really my business is direct
to consumer what about get yoked the
there's um i don't know if you've have
you heard he get yoked i haven't he's
trying to get in to get yoked it's a uh
they have like a bunch of stores in the
valley oh okay it's actually stored it's
armenian uh armenian-owned place um
their stores are flying a lot of times
if it's not a big retailer i'm kind of
spoiled i'm weird no vitamin shop is
[ __ ] huge like the smaller retailers
is kind of it's like a lot to manage for
yeah
yeah yeah it's almost like the trade-off
is like not worth it like you'd rather
just direct a consumer at that point
that's my that's where we make the money
at you know i mean so ambrosia is a full
line of
this this sports nutrition supplements
see we we come from it from a holistic
approach [ __ ] that we coming from it
from a spiritual approach because
every product that we put out is good
for you you know what i'm saying so we
max out on the science we spend the we
put a bag on ingredients that are new to
get exclusivity deals you know what i'm
saying we get third party testing we
have gnc uh certification so
the highest of highest of quality
control we have we've we've been doing
since day one so me and my partners we
had our other companies before this
so it wasn't like a money play it was
like a legacy play like let's do the
dopest [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying and make it affordable so that's
exactly what we did and we wasn't
worried about making money we was just
not wanting to lose money
but like after like a year a year or so
we you know doing taxes we looking at
sales like oh that wasn't that bad for
not even pushing it right so
um when i came back here from arizona
uh i sold my other company
went all in with ambrosia and we just
[ __ ] just been killing it just just
we
started with like doing tours like
united kingdom
united states australia all the english
speaking countries just
hitting the ground hustling old school
style and that [ __ ] works
i was doing a lot of like my marketing
is education on the ingredients and the
importance of these products because
they're hard to sell it's not like just
a fat burner i have a fat burner now but
i barely put a fat burner out less than
a year ago you know i'm saying i've been
in business for years so i went
backwards doing really complicated
products that it's not easy to sell
but it made me a beast with marketing
because you know you and it gave me a
lot of credibility with my my fan base
because i'm educating them on these
ingredients you're not selling them
[ __ ] either it's like not [ __ ]
at all so and i we stand by everything
like we have batch we have
uh uh codes you could scan to see which
batch this came off of and the testing
just in the third so a lot of people
ain't doing that
so these people are smart nowadays you
know what i'm saying it's not 100
necessary to go to that extent but the
fact that we go to that extent it gives
us a lot of credibility and in return it
gives us a lot of respect amongst our
peers which i value
and in turn the cells come in
so you have protein
i mean your name protein you have it you
have a whole line of supplements so what
would i guess what would be your like
let's say like a big brand like ghost
right uh what's like a difference
between like what everyone else is doing
and what you're doing in terms of just
ingredients or i don't know what ghost
is doing ingredient wise that's just an
example but yeah yeah but i think what
they're doing marketing-wise is really
cool no they're killing they got it and
i love their energy they got a dope
energy about their business
about the marketing the branding and i
folks with it i'm a i love marketing i
love people because their branding is
crazy i love people being innovative
about this [ __ ] like mine i take a whole
different approach my [ __ ] is more like
illuminati vibes you know what i'm
saying like you like there's there's
little encrypted messages on labels
even when you pick it up you feel it
it's embossed with hieroglyphics you
know what i'm saying everything means
something and then i name products based
on just different places of the world i
want to include everybody you know what
i mean so
it's a lot of like
just like window is a swahili word for
movement and that's a joint support
product wow um planta's plants in
spanish you know what i'm saying
pachamama is my coffee that's mother
earth like in peru you get your own
coffee yeah i got a coffee and listen
even at high level so it's singles
we buy it from we source our coffee
beans from one family a farm in peru you
know what i'm saying because most coffee
nowadays is like hot dogs
it's just like shitty beans from
wherever you know what i'm saying like
hot dogs is a bunch of mixed up meat
from whatever or whatever animal ours is
single source from one family one farm
so we've been getting from them for
years so we feel good about that so
to honor them we named the the coffee
pacha mama some peruvian you know what i
mean so
just being mindful of the world that we
live in and
you know and making people feel included
you know what i mean that's so i wanted
to ask you uh before you get out of here
you're somebody who's got so much going
on and sometimes i get to the point
where i'm like pushing myself so much in
terms of just
things
that i got my hands in at the same time
that it can become exhausting and like
sometimes take a toll on like the
personal side of my life
um
how do you deal with
managing so much
yeah so i'm over that hump now
so
you know previously it was like
man it was like i didn't have nothing to
give nobody
yeah it's like because you because your
day's over and you just finished
so now it's a little different man
because things are automated
ambrosia it had to sit on my shoulders
for a couple years it has a life of its
own now i barely do content for ambrosia
anymore it's such a machine it's its own
brand now business yeah i mean yeah so
my face is not on the the labels like my
very first company i had to put me on
there so people know it's me so they buy
it but that's a cheap trick to get sales
you know what i'm saying and i didn't
want that for this so i just wanted to
be
like from a to z be excellent with
everything like
the marketing the the names of products
like what's in it the ingredients the
taste
like
everything had to be on point so
it's his own entity now you know what i
mean it's a beast and we we we
constantly have vcs courtney's trying to
throw big
millions of dollars at us to be a part
of it to buy buy a piece by piece yeah
what about um how often do you shoot
content like do you ever just stack it
and then say cool i got another show
i have a ton of [ __ ] so
so this [ __ ] that i'll see a ad i forgot
that i did you know what i'm saying yeah
you're like oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] was a
while ago yeah so it's a lot of [ __ ] so
but i'm always when i think of i don't
like be forcing myself to shoot [ __ ] i
like to be
let the creativity come naturally you
know what i mean or if i'm inspired by
something i'll go and record but i'm not
forcing myself to shoot on a particular
schedule you know what i mean but i am
trying to get more consistent with the
podcasting because i really enjoy that
yeah i mean so
um and
i have i can share the creativity by
having a conversation with somebody else
it ain't just me coming up with
everything right right so but yeah but
but with that and honestly the thing
that i like doing the most um
professionally is stuff for other people
because we also i also have like a small
uh media company in which you know i
launch help people launch youtube
channels and all kind of [ __ ] so
i like doing that you've been doing the
youtube thing for a while yeah i mean
and the social media thing it's crazy
too because like um
i think i might have been following you
already and i saw somebody from arizona
post you
and then i was like oh [ __ ] that's
cinque yeah
what the [ __ ]
like what happened to cnq
and now i know yeah
cause you were like just literally
disappeared off the map
i did his man-up squad was that that was
like prior to willie signing with dtp
right
yeah
and then he got in he got on
still
you know really that's like my little
bro you know what i'm saying
and um
the connect ask him that's that was me
that was my story you know what i'm
saying like literally you know what i
mean god let me tell you something i was
doing radio in boise idaho 2009 when
that album came out and i bought 10
copies from the record store
love you willie
wasn't the strongest bodywork
yeah you know what but it was a moment
for us for our state it was a moment for
a-z he like i i used to tell him like
bro
what the [ __ ] you doing in arizona get
out of here go to atlanta you should
have moved to he should have moved to
atlanta i told him hey tiffany managing
hell with scrap go be in the club i'll
send brett out there so you could just
grease the dj's whatever do what you got
to do play the game
but he wanted to be a big fish in a
small pond and i get it i guess like
also like he had like a record like hood
dreamer with b.o.b which was a little
before it's time because b.o.b hadn't
really popped popular yet that [ __ ] was
dope though he has some [ __ ] he had some
good records body markups are classic
classic the dude is talented but i
remember that they was pushing so hard
so fast to get to drop that album i'm
like i think they [ __ ] up they're
gonna drop an album ain't nobody gonna
[ __ ] with it you know what i'm saying
i think the timing wasn't right
and i think
just spiritually my guy wasn't in a good
space you know saying a good classic uh
era of a z hip hop there was carly
hustle had the street heat of the week
shout out to carly there was exposed
magazine
uh were you ever on the cover of expose
i feel like everybody was eventually i'm
pretty sure i yeah i was i
i know i was i was on the cover i didn't
like it because it was around the time
that all the [ __ ] was happening like
legally you were like damn this
magazines get circulated and i'm [ __ ]
going through it having videos pulled
over youtube like yo take this [ __ ] down
like you know what i'm saying it was
that was a scary time for me a scary
time yeah you still have uh children in
a z or you have just one daughter like
all my i got my my my son my 16 year old
lives with me and my six-year-old lives
with me and my 15-year-old daughter
lives in arizona she go back often yeah
i go out there she comes out here too
but right now she's in dance so i gotta
go out there it's all summer
so i'm surprised you uh you just didn't
get the giant giant giant giant mansion
out there
i don't like arizona she's hot as [ __ ]
man and i don't want to be like killing
it in arizona right that's not
impressive
not at all i want to kill it out here
it's not impressive yeah that's why why
do you think i'm [ __ ] here exactly
you know what i'm saying charles barkley
and his son's jersey's behind you i'm
wearing a diamondbacks hat but i'm not
going back it's so good i go back and
visit a dj i see my family but i'm never
moving back i i i will move back like
when i'm older yeah yeah i mean like in
the peak of my life i'm not living in
phoenix when i retire i might retire in
[ __ ] you know paradise valley or some
[ __ ] but i'm not [ __ ] like for the
record it's [ __ ] beautiful it's great
i'm saying i was in paradise valley
before i left but
i'm with old people like all over it's a
great place to get comfortable
yeah i'm not there yeah that's exactly
what i thought remember i said i was
gonna buy this big-ass house i was like
why would i do that right now i got so
much [ __ ] to do you know what i'm saying
and and to be honest [ __ ] was getting
kind of stagnant for me while i was
there
you know what i'm saying
opportunities creativity all kind of
[ __ ] and you were in miami for a sec
right yeah yeah and i was back and forth
arizona miami
so miami was popping
but um so right now you have your
headquarters are in orange county
you've got you've got a team that just
works with you on everything yep that's
dope man yeah what's it inspired ain't
[ __ ] without my team of course
it ain't my team is the team like we all
you know what i'm saying equal units 100
that's dope man and then uh just you're
going to just keep expanding you say
you're working on a book maybe
yeah i've been writing a book for years
but your book's got to be crazy i'm a
good and you'll know when it's time to
drop it too i'm a good writer but i'm
not a discipline writer so
i haven't written
now i wrote a couple weeks ago but it's
it's sparse you know what i'm saying
also if you just tell your story about
your life could be a movie loki
i mean the on the run [ __ ] yeah what
selling dope going on the run hey if
pain and gain is a [ __ ] movie with
mark wahlberg in the room not a real
story i don't know i think it was i
think it was loosely based on i think it
was okay that's dope
i've been meaning to rewatch that
man put your stomach away bro come on
man that's something
i feel you but we ain't going like that
today sometimes you have to let that gut
hang man
there it is well listen i appreciate you
coming through man um go follow uh this
guy go subscribe to the youtube channel
um go buy some supplements ambrosia yes
sir the pre-workout's mushroom based yes
it is adaptogen so
uh yeah kinetic is the world's first
mushroom-based pre-workout
tastes amazing
you get just this good pure energy but
it also like
adapted just help you uh uh adapt the
stress better you what i'm saying
stressful situations so it's it's bomb i
know people who take like a micro dose
before they work out like legit like i'm
like psilocybin yeah yeah like i don't
microdose is a waste of mushrooms for me
you're a [ __ ] beast
this guy's
[Music]
you know what i'm saying you went to
[ __ ] universal studios where people
are jumping out dressed as monsters on
ella wait no on mdma and troops
yeah you're a wild boy man hey i want to
say to you man i'm proud of you bro like
to seeing
people from the hometown come up and
killing it
yeah dude
i don't know if you remember um the
night y'all took over friday night
flavors
with matlocks
it was no no it was just like a cool
moment and i was there i was like just
hanging out as an intern right right it
was um
i want to say it was like you willy
i remember that night
ocean ocean was there shout out to ocean
shout out to my guy colleague
uh yeah i forgot ocean was in man up
squad
damn y'all had a leg
yeah that feels like a fighter now like
he'd be fighting and [ __ ] you know and
uh like wrestling right yeah he does
illustrations he's like wwe tight yeah
shout out to colleek but yeah no it was
a it was crazy because y'all like just
took over the radio for like two hours
right with the i think it was matlock
squeak squeak boogie they showed love
but it was moving i was moving so wow
you know what i'm saying i blocked a lot
of blessings bro i was in i was in rooms
with some powerful people you know i'm
saying at that time hey but hey honestly
bro
the journey has led you to this 100
and
it's as as crazy as it sounds not the
most
rewarding
gig to be a
mid mid-level successful rapper
because most rappers sign shitty record
deals and then they end up in
this all worked out for you man because
not for sure if i would have made it
back then i probably would have
destroyed myself i was too real yeah i'm
saying i remember i'm with kate slay
talking [ __ ] to him
slapping money out you know what i'm
saying he's doing dumb [ __ ] like i used
to be so like unhinged you know what i'm
saying wait so you you were like
throwing money in casella's face nah we
was all we was doing an interview oh
okay okay you you you slap your favorite
djs like your favorite rapper like
throwing throwing stacks
i would go to new york to pick up money
and then while i was there like little
shawn or whoever sean was that [ __ ]
forward through all the little radio
shits and you know what i'm saying
so yeah i was just i was living the life
but without a deal you know without a
deal without a deal there it is man well
appreciate you pulling up thanks for
having me yes sir yes sir fire